SPEAKER_00: Welcome to Sparks of the Past,
our Traveler game. We're now in Session
SPEAKER_00: 5. Last game, what happened is
the characters finally got into their
SPEAKER_00: fancy sub, the TSS Profondeur.
It is
SPEAKER_00: run by a trans-arc crew who
they've become friends with.
SPEAKER_00: Ayante Valancourt is the
captain. A teen. A teen. I just love that
SPEAKER_00: thing. A teen. Malay Fonter,
Remy Bouchamp, and Sabine Caron are the
SPEAKER_00: other members of the crew that
the group joined. While there's been
SPEAKER_00: moments where they have found
out that there used to be many more crew
SPEAKER_00: and they are not here, they
decided to do a few test runs of their gear
SPEAKER_00: and equipment to see if
everything was working. And they heard that
SPEAKER_00: there was a naval SOS signal
that was being sent to only other naval
SPEAKER_00: ships. While they were at the
Hadal research site and they saw that had
SPEAKER_00: been attacked by terrorists,
they find individual places there still
SPEAKER_00: holding some oxygen, but
they're having difficulties getting people out.
SPEAKER_00: Through some hijinky methods,
they're able to bring an airlock seal
SPEAKER_00: connecting into a pod and get
all the people out. Most of the people
SPEAKER_00: die, but one of them survives.
And literally, by the skin of their
SPEAKER_00: teeth, the one that survives
looks exactly
SPEAKER_00: like Alan Mercer, the
character that they are accused of killing. He
SPEAKER_00: is primarily in a coma as he
is basically taken to
SPEAKER_00: the undersea base Elyon, so he
can actually be helped. While he is
SPEAKER_00: there, he is given some
medical treatment, and a SolSec operative goes
SPEAKER_00: and takes a hand-to-bone
growth scan. This SolSec agent is confronted
SPEAKER_00: by some of the players, and
the SolSec agent is not pleased with this.
SPEAKER_00: Pulls a gun on them and
eventually leaves. The group is
SPEAKER_00: currently still at undersea
base Elyon. And they're trying to decide on
SPEAKER_00: what they're going to do with
Alan Mercer maybe not being dead.
SPEAKER_01: Well, you forgot the part
where Zoe and Kyrian
SPEAKER_01: go and threaten the guy. No, I
said and then they...
SPEAKER_00: I said they interrupted him
and then...
SPEAKER_01: I don't know. Threaten was
more...
SPEAKER_03: He said confront, but yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I... It was much more
antagonistic.
SPEAKER_00: He was highly unprofessional
as I was simply working in
SPEAKER_00: my role as a security officer
on the station attempting to interface
SPEAKER_00: with local law enforcement of
potential conspiracy using our resources.
SPEAKER_01: You were a shatter brat. That
is not at all how that went down.
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan is doing the exact
same thing that I am doing, which is
SPEAKER_03: chuckling to himself watching
this ape fume.
SPEAKER_00: Soshi is actually outside the
medical room.
SPEAKER_00: Where Alan Mercer is, and
she's been peeking through the window when no
SPEAKER_00: one's looking because she's a
robot and can just stand outside on the
SPEAKER_00: water.
SPEAKER_00: But all of you guys can speak
to each other through your radio signals.
SPEAKER_02: Where am I in this?
SPEAKER_00: You would probably be still on
undersea base, Elyon.
SPEAKER_00: I would say the timeline is
probably the characters that went to
SPEAKER_00: confront the Solsa guy have
just returned. And they can be like,
SPEAKER_00: maybe let's not threaten Solsa
SPEAKER_03: people. Are Kiernan and Zoe
back with the group, or are we right
SPEAKER_03: after that confrontation?
SPEAKER_00: I'd say everyone has gone back
to basically the sub that's attached to
SPEAKER_00: the base. So you guys can
either sleep on the sub, or you can try to get
SPEAKER_00: rooms on the base. Take it as
you like.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, I think Kiernan would
just hopefully accompany Zoe to debrief.
SPEAKER_03: If Zoe does not go to Talk to
people about what happened on base and
SPEAKER_03: what Alan Mercer is like.
Kiernan does. We scrambled off
SPEAKER_03: because the agent was there
and we were afraid he was going to do
SPEAKER_03: something to Mercer, so we ran
off. Kiernan is very much debriefing
SPEAKER_03: those who didn't scramble.
Like, guess what? Mercer is alive. You'll
SPEAKER_03: never guess who we met there.
It was fucking crazy. You should have seen
SPEAKER_03: the balls on the chimp. He
went off. I was ready to kick some ass, but
SPEAKER_03: then he drew a gun. I was
like, ooh! A lot of hand gestures.
SPEAKER_01: Excited eyes. Who drew a gun?
SPEAKER_03: Oh, the SoulSec bastard. Well,
he was not the bastard. He is doing job.
SPEAKER_03: But he hates Zoi. Seems to
hate me too. We thought he was going to kill
SPEAKER_03: him. And then Zoi started to
open his mouth around SoulSec guy and he
SPEAKER_03: did not like that. So he
pulled the gun, put to his head and he said,
SPEAKER_03: I'm your boss. It's me. You're
my bitch. Just a whole bunch of that.
SPEAKER_03: Real, real shittery. Just
ready to tear out spine, but he put away Gun.
SPEAKER_03: Zoe seems fine. Zoe, are you
fine? Looks at him. I don't have a hole in
SPEAKER_03: the head. You don't have a
hole in the head. See? He has great, great
SPEAKER_03: attitude about the whole
thing.
SPEAKER_03: That is a good attitude. He
turns to Zoe. Good job. You did a good job.
SPEAKER_03: You have balls of steel. Yes.
SPEAKER_03: I was actually thinking of
rewarding him with food. Is mess hall open?
SPEAKER_03: That sounds like a painful
affliction.
SPEAKER_02: Can you imagine the weights
just pulling all the time? I
SPEAKER_02: heard this figure of speech,
you know?
SPEAKER_02: So no threatening Sosa, guys.
Let's... These people should
SPEAKER_02: first ask questions later and
they have more info than we have lives.
SPEAKER_01: I could have told you
threatening wasn't going to go very well. I
SPEAKER_01: thought you were going to go
and talk to him.
SPEAKER_03: What were we going to talk to
him about? Zoey tried talking to him. Look
SPEAKER_03: where that got him. He got the
gun put ahead. Bad idea to talk to
SPEAKER_03: SoulSec agents. I already knew
this. That's why I went ready to kill
SPEAKER_03: him.
SPEAKER_00: No, I think it's because we
flanked him.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, you're going to blame this
on me, really?
SPEAKER_02: Well, did I stop you? Did I
stop you from blanking him?
SPEAKER_03: No, you didn't, because that's
what we were there to do.
SPEAKER_01: So you were going to kill a
SoulSec officer?
SPEAKER_03: No, no, no. We're not even
armed. No, no, of course not. No, we weren't
SPEAKER_03: going to do that. Only if we
needed to kill the guy.
SPEAKER_02: No, no, no, no, no.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, no, no, we weren't going
to do that.
SPEAKER_02: You know, that's why I love
blanking.
SPEAKER_00: So you went towards Plan A for
asking, but your backup plan was Plan K,
SPEAKER_00: which is Plan Kill Him, and
SPEAKER_02: Plan A didn't really
SPEAKER_00: work out.
SPEAKER_03: Yes, he did not seem to like
the implication. We thought he was there.
SPEAKER_03: I'm not going to lie. When I
showed up, I showed up and I thought we
SPEAKER_03: were going to find Soul Sack
guy with bloody knife in hand, dead Mercer.
SPEAKER_03: Like, oh, that's why I come in
so hot heavy. So that was not the case.
SPEAKER_03: And then he drew the gun on
us. So, hey, that is an interesting piece of
SPEAKER_03: information, though. Guy is
willing to threaten our lives, but not
SPEAKER_03: Mercers.
SPEAKER_02: Emma, do you think you can
meet with this SoulSec agent?
SPEAKER_02: Maybe you can get Intel? No,
no, no. Just
SPEAKER_02: one on one.
SPEAKER_03: No, we already have our guy.
We don't need another guy. We have our guy.
SPEAKER_03: We don't want multiple guys.
See, this is how I hear. Whenever someone
SPEAKER_03: gets disappeared in the unit,
that's how it happens. He has multiple
SPEAKER_03: guys. You don't want multiple
guys. One of them is a rat. You just want
SPEAKER_03: one. One guy.
SPEAKER_02: What guy do we have?
SPEAKER_03: We have, I don't know. You
know the name of the guy. I'm not the brain
SPEAKER_03: guy. Who's our guy? The
inspector, Juro. What's his name? That's our
SPEAKER_03: guy.
SPEAKER_02: We just passed him
information.
SPEAKER_03: I know. That's our guy. We
don't want two guys. Or am I wrong? See, I am
SPEAKER_03: not intelligence guy. I am
just a guy who knows how to not die. But that
SPEAKER_03: is my big fear. Especially
this guy, we don't know if he's working with
SPEAKER_03: the inspector. We don't know
if he's there to truly just kill Mercer.
SPEAKER_02: Well, if he wanted to kill
Mercer, Mercer would be dead. The inspector
SPEAKER_02: we passed the information on
works way up in the city. They may not even
SPEAKER_02: know each other.
SPEAKER_03: Who was it who was even
speaking to the inspector? Who's the guy who
SPEAKER_03: wanted to speak to the
inspector? I believe it was Caspian, no?
SPEAKER_03: Kind of turns. You are a
person who hand off information. You are a
SPEAKER_03: person who's... Yeah, and that
went well. Like my initial...
SPEAKER_02: Like, I used a third party,
that way we're not connected, except I want
SPEAKER_02: to implicate our potential
savior in, you know, being in
SPEAKER_02: a cahoot with, you know,
SPEAKER_03: wanted, you know, alleged
criminals. Okay, so this is the person we
SPEAKER_03: should be asking about this, I
think. At least I need to ask him a
SPEAKER_03: question. Are we done with
Inspector? Have we passed on information and
SPEAKER_03: we don't talk to him anymore?
Are we done with that guy? He doesn't know
SPEAKER_02: he exists. He knows we exist,
but he doesn't know that we gave him any
SPEAKER_02: information.
SPEAKER_03: Which is the whole point. That
is better than whatever is
SPEAKER_03: up Solsack number two's guy's
ass. He does not care if... He
SPEAKER_03: actually... It's less than he
don't know we exist. He actively does not
SPEAKER_03: want us to exist. Yeah. To
specifically answer your question
SPEAKER_02: so that it is clear, SolSec
Inspector No. 1,
SPEAKER_02: that we have passed
information provided that to him. He is
SPEAKER_02: air-gapped from us. We don't
want to talk to him, but if we uncover
SPEAKER_02: other information, we want to
be able to funnel that to him. So, to your
SPEAKER_02: point of, we're not talking to
him, we're not seeking him out unless we
SPEAKER_02: are giving him information.
Just to specifically answer your question. I
SPEAKER_02: like. Book less. Do more. So
is Inspector 2,
SPEAKER_02: who drew guns on you all, that
that guy, I don't particularly care about
SPEAKER_02: him one way or the other right
SPEAKER_03: now. Yes. Good idea. As of
now, what we know, completely independent of
SPEAKER_03: Inspector, dude. Could be bad,
could be good. Probably bad now. Who
SPEAKER_03: knows?
SPEAKER_02: Question is, should we take
next mission? Oh, what is next mission?
SPEAKER_03: Like with, uh, Trendstar. Oh.
Oh. Oh, no, you're talking about two-year
SPEAKER_03: contract? Fuck that. No, I'm
getting off this ship whether you guys
SPEAKER_03: stick around or not. I, you
know, by one month's time, I have been
SPEAKER_03: assured that names will be
cleared in one month by people. He kind
SPEAKER_03: of glares a little bit at
Caspian. So I stay on boat for a month. But I
SPEAKER_03: am not signing two-year
contract. This is not the way. This is not how
SPEAKER_03: someone gains a storied life
and glorious death. It's kind of just
SPEAKER_03: gestures futilely.
SPEAKER_02: I will not stay on ship.
Question is, where do we get ship?
SPEAKER_03: Why do we... Now I was talking
about getting off planet before, when we
SPEAKER_03: had no plan. Now we're talking
about get ship? We should get ship.
SPEAKER_03: Ship sounds fun.
SPEAKER_02: Well, again, to clarify, it is
my understanding of we have another
SPEAKER_02: mission on the sub that can be
accomplished in the next couple of days.
SPEAKER_02: I understand the two-year
contract is not any of our current cups of tea
SPEAKER_02: as far as long-term plans, but
I do believe there will be more missions
SPEAKER_02: related to the sub that In the
coming days. So yes, next mission with
SPEAKER_02: Transtar, not long-term action
with Transtar. Again, to clarify based
SPEAKER_02: on things that have been said.
SPEAKER_03: What is next mission then?
Because I thought it was a deployment whole
SPEAKER_03: thing. I understand what you
say. So what is next thing to do on
SPEAKER_03: submarine then?
SPEAKER_02: Well, I believe someone might
have input on that once they check in with
SPEAKER_02: home base, and I turn and look
at Laura's character, since she is our
SPEAKER_02: super executive.
SPEAKER_01: I am super executive.
SPEAKER_02: Capitan.
SPEAKER_01: I am not the captain.
SPEAKER_02: There is a captain. Capitan
Colbert has a great ring. It just
SPEAKER_02: made you cringe.
SPEAKER_00: I just want to ask something
before we go any further.
SPEAKER_03: You're the one who has
executive in the name. You're the only one in the
SPEAKER_03: group who has the title.
SPEAKER_01: Do you think I'm going to be
in charge of you people? No.
SPEAKER_03: Well, you are! TransStar Day!
SPEAKER_00: You have TransStar Day now!
Yippee! What were you going to say, Patrick?
SPEAKER_00: What I really just want to be
sure is, you guys can obviously get on the
SPEAKER_00: sub and tell the captain it's
time to go, but do you guys want to look
SPEAKER_00: or talk to... I was going
to...
SPEAKER_01: No, I was waiting for a break
in the conversation to ask Doi if there
SPEAKER_01: was any guards posted outside
of the Clone Mercer's room. But the
SPEAKER_01: conversation kind of kept
going.
SPEAKER_00: I know it's just the robot we
have outside. She's the only one watching
SPEAKER_00: them.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, then I'm going to go...
I'm going to go... See if he's cognizant
SPEAKER_01: enough for a conversation. I
don't know if I need any help, like,
SPEAKER_01: shooting people on sight or
having guns. No talking stick.
SPEAKER_01: I mean, I think, if anything,
I forget what Steinbach your character is
SPEAKER_01: because you don't have it in
your name profile there, but, like, you
SPEAKER_01: haven't had a lot of screen
time, so maybe we could go together.
SPEAKER_02: Victor Mendez.
SPEAKER_01: That's what it was. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: So you two are up for walking
to see Alan Mercer's room.
SPEAKER_02: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: As you guys walk up, there are
a few doctors and a few other medics.
SPEAKER_00: There's not a heavy activity.
It's one of those kind of like firefighter
SPEAKER_00: situations where when people
come in, they need a lot of people. But if
SPEAKER_00: everyone's stable, they're
just kind of sitting around and watching
SPEAKER_00: movies on their phone.
SPEAKER_01: They have AirPods, after all.
You could watch them at roller rinks.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. If you guys want to
SPEAKER_00: just try to walk past them to
Alan's area, you can try to do some type
SPEAKER_00: of sneak roll. If you want to
fast talk them, you can try to do some
SPEAKER_00: type of deception roll.
They're not guarding. You guys just bust your
SPEAKER_00: way through. They're not going
to stop you. But if you don't want to be
SPEAKER_00: chronicled for having done it,
you might want to attempt a roll.
SPEAKER_02: Are there other places to look
around?
SPEAKER_00: On the base, yes. But we can
focus on any other place after we're done
SPEAKER_00: with theirs.
SPEAKER_01: I'm sorry, I was trying to
pull up my character. I wasn't listening for
SPEAKER_01: what I'd like to roll to be,
not sneaky, but be inconspicuous.
SPEAKER_02: You can do deception.
SPEAKER_01: I'd love to do deception. My
deception is amazing.
SPEAKER_01: It's a public roll. It's a
normal type. I just hit the yes, there's
SPEAKER_01: nothing special going on.
SPEAKER_00: Correct. Oh, I already hit
roll. No worries.
SPEAKER_00: Absolute success. You're like,
I heard there's a gas leak in Section 4,
SPEAKER_00: too. You should go take some
sensors. There might be some sick people
SPEAKER_00: there. A bunch of people late.
SPEAKER_01: Sweet. Later, people.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, having cleared out any
riffraff that might cause problems,
SPEAKER_01: I will gently enter the room.
I'm not busted in by kicking the door down
SPEAKER_01: or anything like that. Because
he is a genuinely sick person, so I don't
SPEAKER_01: exactly know. I'm being cool,
man. Being cool about it. Because he's
SPEAKER_01: genuinely sick, and me killing
him from fright isn't going to get us any
SPEAKER_01: answers.
SPEAKER_02: That's exactly it. That's
SPEAKER_00: a creep. He is, I would say,
sleeping, but
SPEAKER_00: not in a coma.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. Does he wake when we
enter the room?
SPEAKER_02: No.
SPEAKER_00: Nurse has been going back and
forth. Testing things, so he's not waking
SPEAKER_00: up for that.
SPEAKER_01: Sure. I just, you know, I
wanted to know if we had that PC glow where we
SPEAKER_01: walked in and it was like...
SPEAKER_02: I mean, the big bird glow.
SPEAKER_01: The kick-in-the-door glow.
Wow.
SPEAKER_01: I mean, I just want to get,
like, it's an RP thing. I just want one more
SPEAKER_01: good look at this guy. He
really does look like Mercer. Yes. But a
SPEAKER_01: skinny version of him.
SPEAKER_00: Well, skinny in the fact that
he's probably been in a... not had proper
SPEAKER_00: food and water for a few days.
SPEAKER_01: Right.
SPEAKER_00: Not like he's 30 pounds less.
He's just...
SPEAKER_01: Right. I mean, it's like he's
gaunt as opposed to, like, emaciated.
SPEAKER_01: Right. All right. I will...
SPEAKER_01: Okay, I will actually indicate
to Victor that he maybe wants to do the
SPEAKER_01: questioning at first because
I'm going to see if I can get into his
SPEAKER_01: chart on what I presume is the
computer station nearby.
SPEAKER_00: You can roll a computer roll.
SPEAKER_00: You are looking for three
successes.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, hold on.
SPEAKER_00: There it is. And Steinbach,
you can talk to him at your leisure.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. Well, if he's asleep and
I see Laura go over
SPEAKER_02: and start tapping away at the
computer, I think it's fair to try to at
SPEAKER_02: least give her a moment to see
if she can get in or not before I wake
SPEAKER_02: this guy up.
SPEAKER_01: I can't. You hear the error
message, like, boom, boom, and
SPEAKER_01: I'm like, fuck.
SPEAKER_02: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Give me a minute. I'm like,
this might take a while.
SPEAKER_02: All right. To that then, I
give a nod to Laura's character,
SPEAKER_02: which name I keep forgetting.
No worries, Emma. Emma. I give an nod to
SPEAKER_02: Emma. Step over, and with the
back of my hand,
SPEAKER_02: I press against his upper arm,
and I give him a couple of little shakes.
SPEAKER_02: I'm not trying to violently
shake him, but I am physically putting
SPEAKER_02: pressure so that his body does
move a little bit to wake him up.
SPEAKER_00: He wakes up, and he's a little
groggy, and you see his eyes are a little
SPEAKER_00: out of focus, and... He
gradually gets focus,
SPEAKER_00: and then he looks at you and
he's like,
SPEAKER_02: don't kill me. Well, good sir,
that is
SPEAKER_02: the opposite of our plan. We
are hoping that, you know, here in the
SPEAKER_02: hospital, that you maintain
your health and vitality and continue to
SPEAKER_02: improve.
SPEAKER_00: I saw the video, you were one
of the guys who killed me.
SPEAKER_02: I believe, sir, that you have
seen incorrect information. Perhaps the
SPEAKER_02: medication is hitting you a
little hard and you're a little groggy at
SPEAKER_02: the moment. Clearly someone
missed. Okay.
SPEAKER_02: Can you please confirm your
name?
SPEAKER_00: I'm Alan Mercer.
SPEAKER_01: You're the Alan Mercer? Sorry,
I don't mean to interrupt. I just, I'm
SPEAKER_01: confused. You're the Alan
Mercer? Then who was that who died?
SPEAKER_00: People with Platinum 2
security have pre-prepared
SPEAKER_00: clones that will awake on the
aspect of their original body's death.
SPEAKER_01: Did I know that technology
existed?
SPEAKER_00: Say it's Anyone who has a
genetics of
SPEAKER_00: two would know.
SPEAKER_01: I have zero medically things.
Well, yeah, no, I have zero,
SPEAKER_01: zero. Yeah, no. My science is
zero, so that'd be a
SPEAKER_01: big no from me, dog.
SPEAKER_02: I have to check.
SPEAKER_00: People who are high-ranking
members The
SPEAKER_00: government or Transtar or the
Imperial Navy all
SPEAKER_00: have access to divert a piece
of our
SPEAKER_00: paychecks in a lesser fashion
to guaranteeing that we would be able to
SPEAKER_00: have clone rebirth, but it is
about 30% of our incomes.
SPEAKER_02: Well, for you, sir, I do
believe that was money well spent. But no, my
SPEAKER_02: friends and I were not there
to kill you or any version of you.
SPEAKER_02: Just in the same way that
clearly bad things were aimed at you, we were
SPEAKER_02: also framed in that, that That
forces were
SPEAKER_02: arrayed against us, and likely
the same forces arrayed against us were
SPEAKER_02: the forces that truly killed
you.
SPEAKER_01: I nod along convincingly.
SPEAKER_02: I can roll a Persuasion on
that, maybe?
SPEAKER_00: I'll accept a Persuasion or
Corouse.
SPEAKER_02: Same stat.
SPEAKER_00: We're doing great tonight. It
seems like, okay, that's the story you're
SPEAKER_00: telling me. I understand you
don't want me dead, because if you wanted
SPEAKER_00: me dead, you'd just be killing
me again right now.
SPEAKER_02: Yes. Not only that, but our
people were on the
SPEAKER_02: sub that came to the place
that you were at and pulled bodies
SPEAKER_02: from the near wreckage of the
lab that you were at.
SPEAKER_02: Not only if we wanted you
dead, could we be killing you now, we could
SPEAKER_02: have also just left you there.
We want an answer to this that clears our
SPEAKER_02: name, for we are not the cause
of this problem.
SPEAKER_00: Well, I'm not going to know
any aspect of whether he killed me or not.
SPEAKER_00: My memory last update was six
weeks ago, at least from what I've
SPEAKER_00: heard on the Talon Marine.
SPEAKER_02: Hmm. So would it be safe to
say then that you do not know
SPEAKER_02: of the scientific genetic
information that was
SPEAKER_02: uncovered that was going to be
revolutionary to the Genetics
SPEAKER_02: Association? I'm sorry, I'm
Michael and blanking on the proper
SPEAKER_02: terminology for the Genetics
Bureau.
SPEAKER_00: Where'd my notes go? No, we
had
SPEAKER_00: Suspicions about what we were
doing, but we were still waiting for
SPEAKER_00: evidence. If you're saying
that I had announced I was going to release
SPEAKER_00: information, I obviously find
evidence.
SPEAKER_02: And because you've effectively
lost the last six weeks of your life,
SPEAKER_02: that evidence has itself been
lost as well.
SPEAKER_00: Well, evidence is never lost.
It just sometimes
SPEAKER_00: varies deeper than other
places.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: One of the conditions, though,
of being part of the regenerative aspect
SPEAKER_00: is if you were killed in
public, you were unable to return to the
SPEAKER_00: surface of Jardin and you must
leave in a Navy ship as soon as
SPEAKER_00: capable. I was still
undergoing the neural pathway Aspects
SPEAKER_00: to make sure that I was
correctly handed and that I still had my rote
SPEAKER_00: experiences in me when our
underpod was
SPEAKER_02: attacked by the terrorists.
SPEAKER_00: There were multiple bodies of
high ranking political figures and
SPEAKER_00: transtar figures at Hadal
Research Facility.
SPEAKER_00: If it was a plan to kill
someone possibly as important as me,
SPEAKER_00: they also might just be
destroying the clones of them. So if they strike
SPEAKER_00: the original person, they
would have no place to rise.
SPEAKER_02: Do you know where these clones
are kept?
SPEAKER_00: Yes, they were in the pods in
Hadal.
SPEAKER_02: Ah. Sorry, if you had said
that, I missed it. Apologies.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. Basically, the facility
that you went to
SPEAKER_00: and rescued the people out of
it, it had the scientific
SPEAKER_00: researchers to pull up and
Prepare clone bodies to be reintegrated, as
SPEAKER_00: well as the cloning facilities
necessary to have the bodies prepped. To
SPEAKER_00: grow an individual body, it
takes about three weeks of very expensive
SPEAKER_00: work. So they normally
actually grow the body early and then put it into
SPEAKER_00: a brain dead hypersleep that
when the original
SPEAKER_00: person dies, they're able to
upload the memories and the concepts into
SPEAKER_00: those people. And they're able
to finally wake up and have something in
SPEAKER_00: them beyond just autonomic
responses of heartbeat and breathing.
SPEAKER_02: So it's engrammatic transfer.
SPEAKER_00: Yes. The clones, as far as I
know, because I'm
SPEAKER_00: part of the genetic
Organization are tested monthly to make sure
SPEAKER_00: there's not genetic drift in
them. And if there is genetic drift, those
SPEAKER_00: people are removed and
replaced because without a consciousness,
SPEAKER_00: sometimes cancerous growths
occur as there is not a pattern or
SPEAKER_00: movement.
SPEAKER_02: Let's see.
SPEAKER_01: I am kind of fascinated by all
of this, so I listen on with keen
SPEAKER_01: interest.
SPEAKER_02: I'm there too, right?
SPEAKER_01: No. Oh, I thought it was just
the two of us.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, I'm fine for them
listening in on the comms. Is that okay? Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, that's fine. I didn't
want to repeat with the guns being drawn.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, got it,
SPEAKER_02: got it. Yeah, yeah. I'm just
making sure I'm listening in as well.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, we're broadcasting.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah. I suppose you could
probably text questions to us. Call a
SPEAKER_02: friend.
SPEAKER_00: I also imagine Annette's like
leaning over at the window like, how are
SPEAKER_00: you going? I'm reading lips.
SPEAKER_00: Or hell, you just put one of
your sucker feet on the glass and you just
SPEAKER_00: vibrate through it.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, gosh. Hello, Buzz. I'm
going to choose a human.
SPEAKER_00: But part of a legal statute
that is 160
SPEAKER_00: years old, if we do have a
death, we're not allowed to return to where
SPEAKER_00: we are. We're allowed to go
off to another planet or another colony as
SPEAKER_00: if the death was public and
cannot be explained in another fashion. So
SPEAKER_00: it's why you don't ever hear
of politicians dying of heart attacks.
SPEAKER_01: I guess I had never made that
connection.
SPEAKER_02: I can certainly see the logic
to that rule.
SPEAKER_02: Otherwise, anyone who doesn't
have access to that level of
SPEAKER_02: technology and regeneration,
rebirth, you have societal uprisings and
SPEAKER_02: the like if the powerful and
the rich were able to live indefinitely and
SPEAKER_02: avoid all assassination
attempts.
SPEAKER_00: There's no indefinite aspect.
Our clones age at the same rate we do.
SPEAKER_02: You're telling me that there's
not anyone out there that has purposely
SPEAKER_02: grown a younger clone body and
then transferred their brain engrams into
SPEAKER_02: that younger self?
SPEAKER_00: That is directly against the
code and it would be illegal. Anyone who
SPEAKER_00: did that would probably be a
criminal of the state. The facilities that
SPEAKER_00: we use... Are specifically
linked that we have to have a clone
SPEAKER_00: regeneration every year to
make sure that it is the same age as us.
SPEAKER_00: Anyone who is doing that is
likely part of the underworld as they're
SPEAKER_00: trying to create that
immortality. People would get caught. We do so
SPEAKER_00: much genetic testing in this
world. How can someone get away when every
SPEAKER_00: time you go into a public
building,
SPEAKER_02: you're given a drop of blood?
I
SPEAKER_02: mean, murder is also illegal,
but here we are.
SPEAKER_00: I have no doubt that some
people are using this technology who
SPEAKER_00: are part of the underworld or
are enemies of the state. That is what
SPEAKER_00: happens when the corruption of
capitalism and the free flow of
SPEAKER_00: commerce, like what occurs in
the empire, not things that actually exist
SPEAKER_00: for those who wish to
SPEAKER_02: be righteous so long.
SPEAKER_02: Ask him if he's worried that
SoulSix scanned him while he was sleeping.
SPEAKER_01: Man, that was why I wanted to
break into the computer to see if that
SPEAKER_01: was, like, any reason for
that. Well, I mean, amongst other things, I
SPEAKER_01: wanted to bust into the
computer. By the way, it has been long
SPEAKER_00: enough, you can roll again.
SPEAKER_01: I can't. Okay. Hold on, I have
to pull out my sheet again.
SPEAKER_01: I'd rather move my notes out
of the way, so... Is it
SPEAKER_01: still difficulty eight, or is
it nine now?
SPEAKER_00: It's eight, so.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. Oh my god,
SPEAKER_01: I'm so bad tonight. I rolled
one good roll where it counted, and now I'm
SPEAKER_01: like, this computer, this
Windows machine is defeating me. It's Linux,
SPEAKER_01: that's why.
SPEAKER_00: What about password one, two,
three?
SPEAKER_00: We didn't capitalize the first
letter this time, I mean.
SPEAKER_01: It could be so many things.
There's password123, there's password456,
SPEAKER_01: you never know. What
SPEAKER_02: was the movie, Hacker's
Password, God, something like that?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah. Oh, yeah. Okay,
Pendulette's finest moment.
SPEAKER_01: Fisher Stevens, too, actually,
and that's not a joke. Sorry. I got
SPEAKER_01: distracted. I used to love
that movie.
SPEAKER_02: The Plague. You know. Can I
SPEAKER_02: make an intent on the
computer, too? You're not there. That's right.
SPEAKER_00: I'm just listening. That's
right.
SPEAKER_02: Seeing the text come in, I'll
go, all right, if you are
SPEAKER_02: now here... And there is going
to be, you know, there would
SPEAKER_02: likely have been a news
article about this, but of course, your presence
SPEAKER_02: cannot be put into the public,
which means this whole thing is likely to
SPEAKER_02: get classified. The fact that
you are now once again
SPEAKER_02: under the harsh eye of Solse,
do you think they would have scanned you
SPEAKER_02: or done anything to you while
you have been laying here in bed?
SPEAKER_02: Likely.
SPEAKER_00: There was an affair a few
years ago that
SPEAKER_00: I was asked to investigate,
and it is part of the corruption maybe
SPEAKER_00: you're alluding to. An
individual hacked the
SPEAKER_00: scenario where his clone was
awake while he was, and he set his clone
SPEAKER_00: off into a situation That
would be construed as dangerous by having his
SPEAKER_00: enemies rise up and kill him.
While the original person was safely
SPEAKER_00: away in Solskjaer custody
under a minor crime,
SPEAKER_00: when the public death of the
individual came, he said, oh, no, no,
SPEAKER_00: that's the younger clone, not
me. I can freely go wherever I want to.
SPEAKER_00: I imagine if a SolSec agent
saw me, they would want to test if
SPEAKER_00: I was the copy or the
original.
SPEAKER_01: And that's a genetic marker,
that they can test the age of your cells or
SPEAKER_01: something like that?
SPEAKER_00: For the next seven years, they
can see how long it would have taken my
SPEAKER_00: body to form. When an
individual's body grows and changes over time,
SPEAKER_00: Individual pieces are grown at
different speeds. One day, a new bone
SPEAKER_00: cell may grow. Another day,
having one or too many donuts made that fat
SPEAKER_00: cell. Every cell has a
different mitochondrial age. A clone, for at
SPEAKER_00: least seven years, all their
mitochondrial ages are identical.
SPEAKER_02: Not to mention, your ears
never stop growing, so they can just measure
SPEAKER_02: your ears.
SPEAKER_01: I was just thinking it's the
powerhouse of the cell.
SPEAKER_00: The powerhouse of the cell
itself does have a fine aspect of how much
SPEAKER_00: energy it could ever possibly
produce. It is when a new cell is born and
SPEAKER_00: an old cell dies, it is
redoing those layers.
SPEAKER_02: It's a particularly easy
SPEAKER_02: test. I've learned something
about that in school.
SPEAKER_02: The tannins. No, that's not
tannins. It's another word. But there's the
SPEAKER_02: number of times a cell can be
properly regenerated. There are DNA losses
SPEAKER_02: or something along those
lines. But there is a change in the cell as it
SPEAKER_02: gets older. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: I'm currently in a political
limbo state, though. The fact that I was
SPEAKER_00: not directly pulled from the
cloning vets and then sent on a Navy ship
SPEAKER_00: off-planet, but I'm on-planet,
but the nature of the law says
SPEAKER_00: on the surface is probably
going to be
SPEAKER_02: an interesting legal debate
for scholars of future generations.
SPEAKER_01: Do they just expect you to
live under the ocean for the rest of your
SPEAKER_01: life?
SPEAKER_00: No, we're supposed to go
directly to the ship once we awake. I probably
SPEAKER_00: would have been on a ship now
if the attack on Hadal had not happened.
SPEAKER_01: Oh. I thought you were saying
that they would keep you underwater.
SPEAKER_01: Sorry.
SPEAKER_00: No, they normally have... We
have the base underwater to have The
SPEAKER_00: legality of doing the cloning
not on the surface. Even though he
SPEAKER_00: sees your guys' transtar
uniforms, he's like, there's rumors transtar
SPEAKER_00: does do it in the transtar
zone. And then we normally get a ship
SPEAKER_00: shortly after we are able to
properly write our signatures as we
SPEAKER_02: used to.
SPEAKER_01: So all the people that you
were sheltering with, they were also clones?
SPEAKER_00: Or the scientists working on
the clones.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. I just wonder
potentially how far this
SPEAKER_01: conspiracy might go to kill
the people that know certain things. So
SPEAKER_01: if there were other clones
that were with you and then the base was
SPEAKER_01: attacked, that would be a two
for one kind of deal.
SPEAKER_00: I personally think it is a
future action, not a past one.
SPEAKER_01: Can you clarify?
SPEAKER_02: You think they're going to try
to kill me?
SPEAKER_00: No, I think they're going to
try to kill someone who had a clone there.
SPEAKER_00: Now they don't have a clone.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, I see what you're saying.
SPEAKER_02: They're deleting the backup
before they delete the project.
SPEAKER_01: Do you have any idea who it
might be? Somebody who was connected to your
SPEAKER_01: project?
SPEAKER_00: It has to be someone of a
minister rank or 100.
SPEAKER_01: If you're not a senator,
you're a minister, that's right. Sorry, I was
SPEAKER_01: writing notes and I thought it
was a senator.
SPEAKER_00: If there is an aspect of the
conspiracy that you are uncovering where
SPEAKER_00: you have seen people of a high
political rank, in all likelihood they
SPEAKER_00: were in my pod. My pod was
only the political,
SPEAKER_00: like, Politburo type of people
While other particular airlock areas were
SPEAKER_00: for high ranking Navy
officials or chairmen's of the board of
SPEAKER_00: transtar, things like that.
They don't intermix us because they feel
SPEAKER_00: there's an idea that if we are
awoken before we understand an
SPEAKER_00: individual's secrets, memories
might be implanted in someone who goes
SPEAKER_00: somewhere else.
SPEAKER_02: Ask him if he thinks we can
help each other.
SPEAKER_02: I know that you do not
entirely trust
SPEAKER_02: us at this moment, but we are
trying to clear our names.
SPEAKER_02: We were set up likely by the
same group who killed you originally as
SPEAKER_02: part of their larger plan. I
don't understand how it would necessarily
SPEAKER_02: benefit me. Let me break it
down and then you can possibly give a better
SPEAKER_02: argument. If I'm seen
associating with you, people would
SPEAKER_00: construe that I know whatever
memory
SPEAKER_00: I was killed to contain,
versus me attempting to scoot off the
SPEAKER_00: planet under legal aspects
SPEAKER_02: of my clone. If they
SPEAKER_02: have attempted to kill you
once, or finding information that the then
SPEAKER_02: you felt was important enough
to hold press conferences to share with
SPEAKER_02: the public The public that you
theoretically served in your previous
SPEAKER_02: life, if the previous you felt
that it was worth getting that
SPEAKER_02: information out, us working
together is the best way
SPEAKER_02: to get that information out.
Now, if you want to go cower in this new
SPEAKER_02: life, this second chance,
Fine. We'll go through and we can start
SPEAKER_02: talking to people about... And
then I start rattling off telling him
SPEAKER_02: what we learned from the drive
that we got. So now he has the
SPEAKER_02: information in this life that
he had in the previous life. And
SPEAKER_02: theoretically, he's now stuck
knowing what he knew in the past.
SPEAKER_00: Well, make you know. I'll give
you this compromise. If you keep me
SPEAKER_00: safe here... Until a Navy ship
can put me in orbit, when I am
SPEAKER_00: put on that Navy ship, I will
give you the personal access
SPEAKER_02: codes to my house and my
computer.
SPEAKER_02: I can see a lot of value in
that. And I can see the value in
SPEAKER_02: you of getting a squad of
bodyguards to keep you alive and keep you
SPEAKER_02: safe.
SPEAKER_00: I can't get to the surface. If
I get to the surface, I've broken the
SPEAKER_00: law, and even Navy people
would be allowed to just kill me. Right. I
SPEAKER_00: need to have a Navy escort to
get me off planet.
SPEAKER_02: Yes, and you need to go from
underwater directly into space. Do not pass
SPEAKER_02: go of being on the land. This
is go straight to space.
SPEAKER_00: That's the compromise I have
for you.
Okay.
SPEAKER_02: Do you... Have you been given
a timeline for when a naval ship
SPEAKER_02: will be ready for you?
SPEAKER_00: I was given a timeline when I
was on Hadal, and then Hadal was
SPEAKER_00: destroyed.
SPEAKER_01: Right, but do you have any
faith that that schedule has been moved or
SPEAKER_01: just turned off is what my
brain keeps trying to say, and that's not the
SPEAKER_01: word I want to have. Cancel.
Cancel. That's turned off.
SPEAKER_00: That was your Isaac moment.
Turn off. Shut, shut. Turn down. No, no.
SPEAKER_00: Turn off. No, no.
SPEAKER_01: Too loud.
SPEAKER_00: Too loud.
SPEAKER_01: I'm saying up to everything.
Up, up. No, honey, you mean down.
SPEAKER_00: I know that more time has
occurred past the deadline I was supposed to
SPEAKER_00: have. What probably occurred
is a Navy ship went by and saw Hadal
SPEAKER_00: destroyed. And so they
canceled my ticket.
SPEAKER_02: Well, I... And Victor starts
SPEAKER_02: chuckling in the room. And I
think this is going to... I would like to
SPEAKER_02: cinematically adjust this to,
like... The end of the third act of an
SPEAKER_02: episode of Leverage, and he's
like, all right, I think I know where a
SPEAKER_02: Navy ship that we can get you
to is. He turns and looks at Emma and
SPEAKER_02: says, all right, let's go
steal us a defense boat.
SPEAKER_02: If I recall, our characters
are aware that there was a sunken patrol
SPEAKER_02: boat that sank in the water
near here. Yep. We had the crazy idea at one
SPEAKER_02: point of like, oh, well, if we
get that and we're able to fix that ship,
SPEAKER_02: we can then fly off into
space. If it is technically a Navy ship and we
SPEAKER_02: are able to repair it at least
enough to get into orbit, we can get this
SPEAKER_02: guy off planet without having
broken the lock. Yep. Other than the laws
SPEAKER_02: we break in getting materials
to solve it.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So I feel that is a good
run for your guys' thing?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Who would like to have their
next scene with the group?
SPEAKER_02: And I'm going to step away
real quick from the computer. I'll be right
SPEAKER_02: back. Okay. I'm interested in
helping with this
SPEAKER_00: ship recovery project. Okay.
So you're doing the ship recovery.
SPEAKER_00: Cole, Peter, Damien, do you
want to work on ship recovery, or do you
SPEAKER_00: want to do something on the
base?
SPEAKER_02: I got mechanical in itself
with the ship recovery. I mean,
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan is interested in ship
recovery, for sure. What
SPEAKER_03: are we doing about, like, Do
we need to
SPEAKER_03: do any convincing of the crew
in order to do that?
SPEAKER_00: There's two ways you guys can
try to do it. You guys could rent, like,
SPEAKER_00: personal little subs, go in
there in actual
SPEAKER_00: subsuits, jump out, and go to
work on the wreck. Or you could try to
SPEAKER_00: convince the profondeur to
basically stay by the wreck while you guys go
SPEAKER_00: back and forth and repair it.
If the profile is there, you guys need to
SPEAKER_00: get this done way faster than
you guys having to rely on your guys' own
SPEAKER_00: oxygen basically back and
forth every single rut.
SPEAKER_03: Kind of looks to the rest. I
mean, he can Can you give me an admin role?
SPEAKER_00: The Prime Minister was killed
in a terrorist attack as his home was
SPEAKER_00: blown up this morning.
SPEAKER_02: Say what?
SPEAKER_00: The Prime Minister was—his
home was blown up this morning.
SPEAKER_02: And the news is saying he's
confirmed dead?
SPEAKER_00: They're saying his home was
blown up. They presume he's dead. But you
SPEAKER_00: guys know this house really
well. That's where you dropped out the cat.
SPEAKER_02: No. It was a dog. It was a
Pargy. Oh, yeah, a Pargy.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, I know that that is. What
are the leads that they're
SPEAKER_02: releasing? Like, terrorist
group claim...
SPEAKER_00: Suspected separatists.
SPEAKER_02: They're obviously trying to
keep the knowledge out that the public
SPEAKER_02: demands to know. Just
SPEAKER_02: like the killing of the guy
you guys killed.
SPEAKER_02: Well, that is interesting news
that I will relay to the group when we're
SPEAKER_02: together again.
SPEAKER_03: Is that now? Have we gathered
up?
SPEAKER_02: I don't know.
SPEAKER_03: Then let's do so. Let's just
say we have. We've done it.
SPEAKER_02: Yes, we gather so that we can
find out about what we're going to do now
SPEAKER_02: with the undersea ship.
SPEAKER_00: Convince the Profunder or go
into your presence zone.
SPEAKER_01: I'd like to convince the
Profunder, I'm just not entirely sure how.
SPEAKER_02: The Profunder, because it's
fresh.
SPEAKER_01: My accent is probably better
in character than out of character.
SPEAKER_01: I'll just roleplay that I said
it right. I have
SPEAKER_02: a thing. One second. While we
are here, what is
SPEAKER_02: ATN Valcourt doing?
SPEAKER_00: Do we know, like, what— He's
refueling the ship at the base. He's
SPEAKER_00: cleaning up. He's organizing
the cleanup of new air filters.
SPEAKER_00: They're taking off some of the
research stuff that was on the profunder
SPEAKER_00: that they don't need anymore,
and he's selling that to also replace
SPEAKER_00: the emergency pods that you
guys used on the rescue. He's
SPEAKER_00: finding out paperwork because
rescuing each of these people did have a
SPEAKER_00: bounty on it.
SPEAKER_02: Anything in there that I would
be able to help him with?
SPEAKER_02: I'm
SPEAKER_02: going to do
SPEAKER_02: a streetwise roll and we're
going to see
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, no. I got nothing, guys.
I got nothing.
SPEAKER_02: I agree in the approach of
trying to feel out the
SPEAKER_02: Profundur and see if Captain
or maybe Sabine
SPEAKER_02: has any inclination to assist
us in this, but I don't know how to
SPEAKER_02: approach it. I'm not boys with
Valcourt like that.
SPEAKER_01: We could... Go full rogue, try
to
SPEAKER_01: convince Valkor that it's to
his benefit to rescue the ship on behalf of
SPEAKER_01: Transtar, because it would be
more salvage, essentially. But
SPEAKER_01: we have to be able to get it
up off the ocean floor, so in a sense we
SPEAKER_01: have to repair it and then
steal it.
SPEAKER_01: That's my working theory at
the moment. Is there a way I can find out
SPEAKER_01: how messed up this Imperial
Lines wreck is a wreck?
SPEAKER_02: You guys don't have enough
sensors for that distance.
SPEAKER_01: I do have a robot, though.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, she can start walking. I
like to swim.
SPEAKER_01: I don't want to just volunteer
a character to do things, Annette, but
SPEAKER_01: I'm just like, you're very
versatile.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, in this, I want to make
this clear. Normally, that would be the
SPEAKER_02: case. Normally, I would be
like, don't roleplay my character. But in
SPEAKER_02: this game, in Traveler, I like
that the robot is of service.
SPEAKER_02: So by you giving me commands,
it's actually in character, and I like it.
SPEAKER_02: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: I just want to be respectful
of your agency. I know.
SPEAKER_02: I know. So I'm making that
kind of like X card clarification that you
SPEAKER_02: guys are allowed to request
things of Saichi. You're allowed to say,
SPEAKER_02: hey, robot, go do this useful
thing. And yeah, that tickles me. Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, well then in that case,
yeah, I'll turn to Psyche and just be
SPEAKER_01: like, can you, not just in a
polite way,
SPEAKER_01: but do you think it's within
your skill set to go and evaluate the ship
SPEAKER_01: and what it would take to
repair it?
SPEAKER_02: See, now that question, that
is an interesting question. Because,
SPEAKER_02: let me see if it's within
my...
SPEAKER_02: I don't have any engineering
skill. I am not programmed for engineering.
SPEAKER_00: But you could come the video
back to them.
SPEAKER_02: I can. I can do the recon.
Recon is something I can do, but I cannot
SPEAKER_02: make an evaluation. So I will
be a remote drone, but I
SPEAKER_02: cannot make an assessment
myself.
SPEAKER_00: Is Annette the drone? Or does
she control the drones? I mean,
SPEAKER_02: like, in that regard, I
probably, ooh, I could just...
SPEAKER_02: In my robotic assessment, do I
feel like the drones are better at this
SPEAKER_02: capably than me walking along
the sea floor?
SPEAKER_00: Problem is, it'll take most of
the energy to even get there, and then
SPEAKER_00: they wouldn't be able to get
back.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, the drones themselves are
not capable enough for that distance?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, you're looking at
probably 20, 30 miles.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, then in that case, yes,
absolutely, I will take the job. I will...
SPEAKER_02: I will go on a 20-30 mile
excursion and then
SPEAKER_02: collect and beam back data.
Before you go, though,
SPEAKER_01: I would like to, like, do we
have any training engineers who will be
SPEAKER_01: able to interpret this
information that's coming back? Like, wanting to
SPEAKER_01: repair a ship is great as long
as we know people who can repair a ship.
SPEAKER_01: I don't know how to repair a
ship. I can probably wire the electronics
SPEAKER_01: of a ship, but it needs to not
be flooded with water.
SPEAKER_02: You know, we could tell the
crew of our sub that we need to repair this
SPEAKER_02: ship and send in the space to
fulfill Transtar's end of the contract.
SPEAKER_01: What contract?
SPEAKER_02: The secret cloning to get them
off planet.
SPEAKER_01: That's a government thing.
That's not a Transtar thing.
SPEAKER_02: No, but like you said,
Transstar was the one doing it. That's why it was
SPEAKER_02: being done at a Transstar
base.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, I see what you're saying.
That we're contractually obligated to do
SPEAKER_01: this for this guy.
SPEAKER_02: Yes.
SPEAKER_01: That's a better... It might
even be partially true.
SPEAKER_00: The best lies are so salted
and true. Right. So, by the way, a
SPEAKER_00: net moves at about 8 miles an
hour, which is like way faster than any
SPEAKER_00: human, too. So...
SPEAKER_01: Well, either way, I feel like
her reconnaissance is worthwhile because
SPEAKER_01: even if we go to the
Profondeur and we're like, hey, we need to do this
SPEAKER_01: thing, they're going to have
to send a recon team anyway to figure out
SPEAKER_01: what needs to be done.
SPEAKER_00: So I just wanted to have you
guys understand what the retort will be of
SPEAKER_00: it's a transtar problem. They
would say, well, why don't we just have a
SPEAKER_00: naming person pick them up
SPEAKER_02: and then a naming person ship
them out?
SPEAKER_02: Because where's the glory in
that? You're like, because then it would be
SPEAKER_02: a
SPEAKER_00: Trans-Star Day? He would not
have a Trans-Star Day, as I think both of
SPEAKER_00: you guys' opinions are.
SPEAKER_01: We would not have a Trans-Star
Day.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. If anyone has a Grouse
or Persuade, I'm happy to have them talk to
SPEAKER_00: the captain and send them to
go in.
SPEAKER_01: I have Carouse at 2, and
Carouse is based off of Social,
SPEAKER_01: and I have a 1 in that, so I
essentially have a 3. I don't know
SPEAKER_01: if anyone has anything better
than that. What about you, Cass?
SPEAKER_02: I have Carouse at 0, but I
have a Social at 1. I could Age you, maybe.
SPEAKER_02: Or I could inspire you with
some leadership.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, we should have done that
with the computer thing. I forgot that.
SPEAKER_02: It's vital that you get this
done. But I believe in you because you've
SPEAKER_02: been manipulating people your
whole life. It's an inherent ability that
SPEAKER_02: we develop as babies. And with
your many years of service, I'm sure that
SPEAKER_02: you've honed it to a
fine-edged sword.
SPEAKER_01: I like how you took my
negative and made it a positive. That's
SPEAKER_01: appreciated.
SPEAKER_02: See, that's leadership. You're
so manipulative.
SPEAKER_01: Right? That's a lot of
successes. Damn.
SPEAKER_00: So you definitely have a boon
in this role.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I do. All right, I will
go talk to...
SPEAKER_01: I will go to him with the
impression that I'm coming to him in
SPEAKER_01: confidence and secret and be
like, I have found out this thing.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, and I just want to come
to you because you're the captain and I've
SPEAKER_01: come to respect your
leadership in these things.
SPEAKER_00: And you love the crew.
Remember, he gave props to the crew for saving
SPEAKER_00: people.
SPEAKER_01: He did. He was, yeah, we
worked together on saving people. Your
SPEAKER_01: efforts were appreciated as
well as the expenditure of your resources.
SPEAKER_01: But we have a small problem
that In that one of them is an individual
SPEAKER_01: who legally must get off
planet and it is something of a... I keep
SPEAKER_01: saying TriStar, like we're a
movie company. The TransStar
SPEAKER_01: responsibility. Yeah, the
little horse that goes across. So I feel
SPEAKER_01: like... If we were able to do
this, it would be quite the feather in his
SPEAKER_01: cap, but it may require
salvaging and repairing the ship that's at the
SPEAKER_01: bottom of the sea. And like, I
want to give him the Reader's Digest
SPEAKER_01: version of the clone story
without giving too much away. And again, I'm
SPEAKER_01: trying to keep that as like,
I'm conveying this in confidence because I
SPEAKER_01: trust him and I'm trying to
endear goodwill between the two of us, even
SPEAKER_01: though I'm kind of
manipulating him.
SPEAKER_00: Roll that beautiful bean
footage.
SPEAKER_01: How do I do a boon again? Hold
on. You go down here and it's normal
SPEAKER_01: type.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, normal boon.
SPEAKER_01: Bean footage. Bean footage,
not that boon footage. All
SPEAKER_01: right. Cross your fingers. Oh,
that looks good. Yes, that was so good.
SPEAKER_00: He's like... So, what I'm
going to do...
SPEAKER_00: Is I'm going to say that we
are still absconded on
SPEAKER_00: rescue operations and we are
attempting to hunt down
SPEAKER_00: evidence of the people that
attacked Hadal and we will not find them as
SPEAKER_00: we pass this area.
SPEAKER_01: Got it. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: So can you get the rest of the
crew? We're all filled up and ready to go
SPEAKER_00: once everyone gets on board.
We'll start heading out.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. I relay this
SPEAKER_01: to Sakji because I'm like,
hey, we're coming your way.
SPEAKER_00: She's going to be there by the
time you guys leave.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, then I'll just be like,
lay low and then sneak back on board, but
SPEAKER_01: give us the understanding of
whatever recon you can do in between then,
SPEAKER_01: and then I'll just try to
patch it into the notes of the ship. So I
SPEAKER_01: don't want to look like we
were presumptuous. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: All right. Bitty bitty. All of
you guys get back on the boat. Takes you
SPEAKER_00: guys about 45 minutes to an
hour. They do the final kind of checks.
SPEAKER_00: While you guys are sailing
there, anyone who wants to
SPEAKER_00: do repair work on the Imperial
Line ship, You're going to want to
SPEAKER_00: do your backsuit rolls, and
you're going to want to kind of get prepped
SPEAKER_00: to jump out the moment you
guys get there. So...
SPEAKER_00: Check, check! Anyone who wants
to get off, do your backsuit roll.
SPEAKER_02: I will do that, and I would
like to buddy up with someone so we can
SPEAKER_02: double-check each other's
setups. Right here, right here, right here.
SPEAKER_00: So every double-checker gets a
boon.
SPEAKER_01: What is Vaxuit based off of?
SPEAKER_00: Vaxuit.
SPEAKER_01: No, no, no, but like Dex.
Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Really? I thought it was...
Normally it's intelligence or education of
SPEAKER_00: you knowing to put it on.
Moving around the Vaxuit as a Dex.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, I apologize then. I just
went off of what its
SPEAKER_02: base role was, but putting it
on is education. Either
SPEAKER_02: way, I have that same bonus or
higher, whether it's education or
SPEAKER_02: intelligence.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so Coles has a failure
even with the
SPEAKER_00: boom. Everyone...
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan will ask politely if
he can get a double check as well, but he's
SPEAKER_03: going to roll just for himself
to put it on.
SPEAKER_00: I will say...
SPEAKER_01: Oh, go ahead. I have vac suit
at zero and education at three, so
SPEAKER_01: I can probably roll pretty
good to do the check. I just have zero skills
SPEAKER_01: once I'm outside the ship to
do anything. I don't know how useful I
SPEAKER_01: would be. I'm willing to try,
though. Okay. Well,
SPEAKER_01: it's a good roll.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. I will say that Peter
and Victor's Vax suit rolls are
SPEAKER_00: enough to overcome Kolb's bad
way. Okay. Because they're all
SPEAKER_00: double-checked. Okay.
SPEAKER_02: Lower the money check.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah. Okay. So Vax suit is
education. Education is so good.
SPEAKER_01: Do I get a boon because I'm
being double-checked, or do I... Yeah, I
SPEAKER_01: really get the boon.
SPEAKER_00: Basically, we've come to the
conclusion you're only not going to get a
SPEAKER_00: boon is if you don't have the
time to do double-checks.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Boom. You're good to go.
SPEAKER_01: I'm so good at putting suits
on.
SPEAKER_00: So, Annette, you're at the
wreck. Yay! It is...
SPEAKER_00: Definitely it was crushed by
the pressure. They somehow
SPEAKER_00: went into the water and then
they went lower than the ship's rating
SPEAKER_00: because handling the void of
space is very different than handling the
SPEAKER_00: pressure underwater.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, the spaceships are built
for pressure between zero and one.
SPEAKER_00: Well, even if they're built
for some pressure, like they're built for
SPEAKER_00: atmosphere, they're built for
like, let's say you're going to a gas
SPEAKER_00: giant, there's going to be
some pressure there. Sure. But it's not going
SPEAKER_00: to be like the level of actual
water.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, it's something like
every
SPEAKER_02: 20 feet or something
underwater adds an atmosphere of pressure. So if
SPEAKER_02: they're 60 feet down, they're
in four atmospheres of pressure, which is
SPEAKER_02: a lot more than just walking
around.
SPEAKER_00: It was a Futurama joke, you
guys.
SPEAKER_02: At one point, someone asked a
professor what pressure the ship can
SPEAKER_02: handle. He goes, it's a
spaceship! So it can handle between zero and
SPEAKER_02: one. And then the ship
immediately collapses in on itself.
SPEAKER_02: Got it. That show is for
nerds. I didn't watch it. I
SPEAKER_02: watched most of it. Not for
all nerds. For nerds.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. It is for nerds. Not all
nerds. Not all nerds.
SPEAKER_01: Not all nerds. I don't know. I
never liked that show very much.
SPEAKER_00: So as you're kind of like
going down and you're exploring the boat,
SPEAKER_00: you're noticing some odd
things about the markings.
SPEAKER_02: For example, the Soleimani,
like, navy
SPEAKER_02: symbol,
SPEAKER_00: normally they're, like,
painted on with, like, very, like, cool paints
SPEAKER_00: that can survive reentry. It's
a big sticker.
SPEAKER_00: And, yeah, the sticker is the
size of, like, a billboard, but it's a
SPEAKER_00: sticker.
SPEAKER_02: Can I give it a little tug?
Does it peel?
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. There's now coral a
little underneath
SPEAKER_00: it.
SPEAKER_02: I'm not going to do too much
destruction to it, but If I peel a little
SPEAKER_02: bit of a corner, if I just
kind of make a little, I'm gesturing with my
SPEAKER_02: camera off, I'm awesome.
SPEAKER_02: If I just kind of, you know,
Kind of the reverse.
SPEAKER_00: It was meant for them to keep
replacing it with different stickers.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, okay. So it's like a race
SPEAKER_02: car.
SPEAKER_00: It's got a vinyl wrap. Yeah,
but why would you
SPEAKER_00: want to put down different
polarities in Confederation space?
SPEAKER_00: Why would you?
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, this is all shady now.
SPEAKER_01: All levels are shady.
SPEAKER_00: I will say by the level of
crustaceans on it, it sunk about 40 years
SPEAKER_00: ago.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, okay. So if I sent back
the call signal to the profunder, they
SPEAKER_01: wouldn't necessarily be able
to find it in their records?
SPEAKER_02: Well, this is all a part of
the information that I capture with the
SPEAKER_02: camera so that I can send it
back.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I guess I was jumping
the gun there.
SPEAKER_00: I'm sorry. You can walk in, by
the way. Okay. There are
SPEAKER_00: corpses. Okay. I record those
without touching them.
SPEAKER_00: They are in Vax suits that...
SPEAKER_00: They don't look damaged. It
looks like the people died from trauma. It's
SPEAKER_00: almost like if...
SPEAKER_00: If I had you in a vac suit and
I threw you around at 30 Gs, you're still
SPEAKER_00: dead, even though the vac suit
is fine. Yeah, yeah, yeah. It's
SPEAKER_00: the Tony Stark is just the
soup inside the can. Exactly.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I mean, if you break
your neck, you still broke your neck.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. But because they're all
still perfectly hermetically sealed, these
SPEAKER_00: people are basically mummified
in there.
SPEAKER_02: Gross. Gross. Gross.
SPEAKER_00: Well, I record it all. Yeah.
Okay. Without defiling it. So it would have
SPEAKER_00: taken you, let's say, about an
hour to get there. I would say about 30
SPEAKER_00: minutes to explore the outside
and about another 30 minutes for you to
SPEAKER_00: kind of find a rend in it for
you to fit through to get it there. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: And about that time, the
profondeur is going to arrive. And everyone who
SPEAKER_00: is in a vac suit or wants to
get out in their own way, be like, I'll
SPEAKER_00: just swim. They can go out the
airlock.
SPEAKER_01: I don't feel like that's going
to work out very well.
SPEAKER_01: Did you... Can we... How do we
know the information that
SPEAKER_01: Is it like popped up on our
visors? Did she tell us?
SPEAKER_00: You guys did all the work to
get private communicators.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. Just want to confirm
that. I want to investigate this whole
SPEAKER_01: sticker situation. I mean, I
guess it's kind of a
SPEAKER_01: null thing since we're going
to be stealing the ship anyway, but that is
SPEAKER_01: a curious avenue. That's
suspicious.
SPEAKER_00: Yep. So the ProFunder is going
to leave you guys here and they're going
SPEAKER_00: to come back in 30 minutes.
Okay. Because they don't want a
SPEAKER_00: big record of them staying
right here on it.
SPEAKER_01: All right. That makes sense.
Oh, okay.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. Well...
SPEAKER_01: Ah, itchy nose. Is it
completely depressurized? Like, is this
SPEAKER_01: whole ship full of water, or
are there parts that are still good?
SPEAKER_00: Well, so people who want to
slip into the cracks who actually have to
SPEAKER_00: worry about their back suits,
because a robot is like, if I get a little
SPEAKER_00: scratched up, it's like the
end of the world. You guys need to actually
SPEAKER_00: worry you go and get pierced.
So anyone who wants to get in is going to
SPEAKER_00: take a back suit dex to get in
without damage.
SPEAKER_02: Are all of us going?
SPEAKER_01: Anyone who wants to go. But
you have to roll a Vax suit roll to get out.
SPEAKER_01: Or swim, apparently. That's an
option.
SPEAKER_02: Excuse me. Are you saying we
now need to make a Vax suit
SPEAKER_00: moving roll? Yes. To jump out?
Dexterity to get in through the cracks on
SPEAKER_00: the ship. But that's not a
boon.
SPEAKER_01: No boon.
SPEAKER_02: No boon. Vax suit dex.
SPEAKER_01: Did I roll?
SPEAKER_00: I don't know, we all
SPEAKER_02: rolled.
SPEAKER_01: Oh my god, I failed so bad.
Everyone who failed just can't get it.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, fuck, I don't want to
die.
SPEAKER_02: Everyone failed?
SPEAKER_00: Everyone who failed. Alan
failed. No, Alan succeeded. Everyone else
SPEAKER_00: failed.
SPEAKER_02: I succeeded.
SPEAKER_03: Do any of us need to discuss
what we were equipped with? I think Kiernan
SPEAKER_03: would just try to have...
SPEAKER_00: You have a failure. Kolb, I
see Alan. I don't
SPEAKER_00: see Steinbux.
SPEAKER_02: Not what I was asking.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, okay. I'm just like, but
I... Okay, sorry. I thought you were saying
SPEAKER_01: like... Steinbux. Yeah, he's
fine.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so again, everyone who
has a success can go inside. They can try
SPEAKER_00: to find a way to actually open
the hatches so other people can get in.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: And then Peter had a different
question that I misunderstood. And Peter,
SPEAKER_01: what's your question?
SPEAKER_03: What are we coming in equipped
with? I know we discussed those harpoon
SPEAKER_03: guns before. How much
ammunition do they have?
SPEAKER_00: The harpoon guns normally only
have two or three harpoons. Anyone who
SPEAKER_00: has machinery-type things or
SPEAKER_00: computer-type things are going
to be having the repair tools you guys
SPEAKER_00: were shown in the operations.
SPEAKER_00: Anyone who has a mechanic,
even Zero, has a mechanic set of tools.
SPEAKER_00: Anyone who has an electronic
set of tools.
SPEAKER_02: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: And engineering as well.
Because it's going to take the cavalcade of
SPEAKER_00: everything to get everything
going. But let's talk about the people
SPEAKER_00: who have gotten inside, okay?
So we're looking at Steinbach, Cole,
SPEAKER_00: and Alan. Of you three, do any
of you have
SPEAKER_00: mechanics?
SPEAKER_02: I have mechanic at zero. I
have mechanic at... I definitely have
SPEAKER_02: mechanic. One second.
SPEAKER_01: Excuse me.
SPEAKER_02: Let me pull it up. And I
apologize. My laptop
SPEAKER_02: decided to just close itself.
It should have cut itself off entirely, so
SPEAKER_02: I'm rebooting in. But I do
believe I have my computer. I also have to
SPEAKER_02: switch to my laptop. I'm
lending my computer to someone, so I will be
SPEAKER_02: right back. I have a mic. I
have a mic. Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: So, Alan, can you roll that
mechanic to intelligence
SPEAKER_00: with a boon? Because I imagine
Cole will be helping you.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, yeah, I will. With a boon.
So,
SPEAKER_02: intelligence, mechanic, boon.
Roll.
SPEAKER_02: Yay! What a roll.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, on that perfect roll,
I'm going to say you've gotten all the
SPEAKER_00: players in. You have sealed
all the major holes.
SPEAKER_00: There are still locked doors,
but all the massive explosions on the
SPEAKER_00: outside, you have basically
moved plates around to at least get it that
SPEAKER_00: if you pressurized it, it
would be able to re-pressurize. Or for
SPEAKER_00: medically sealed. Yeah, that's
going to take you and Colt 30 minutes. So
SPEAKER_00: everyone else can act in that
time, but you guys are literally welding
SPEAKER_00: during all that time. Yeah,
SPEAKER_00: and Peter, you are able to
enter now, because they've opened up all the
SPEAKER_00: hatches with that 7-plus roll.
SPEAKER_03: Alrighty. The only other thing
I guess he would establish upon
SPEAKER_03: entering, is it feasible to
have taken multiple
SPEAKER_03: weapons of these harpoon guns?
Like, is it musket-style, where you can,
SPEAKER_03: like, you mentioned there's
only two or three for each
SPEAKER_00: It is more like they're just
unwieldy if you're trying to swim with
SPEAKER_00: them. So one of them is
probably about, yeah, musket size, and then you
SPEAKER_00: keep like one or two of the
extra harpoon strapped to your back.
SPEAKER_03: I see. It sounds like he's
only able to carry one.
SPEAKER_03: Either way, now that he's able
to enter, he enters and stuff like that,
SPEAKER_03: but he's just keeping a keen
eye for
SPEAKER_03: threats, really. He's not
quite sure how best to do that in this new
SPEAKER_03: environment, but it's a lot of
SPEAKER_00: So you do see all the back
suits and the corpses that other people saw.
SPEAKER_00: You do notice that the
pressurization explosion did happen on the
SPEAKER_00: primary main deck. You can't
tell
SPEAKER_00: why the main deck exploded the
way it did, but
SPEAKER_00: this seems to be the main
pieces. Now, all the doors are going to take
SPEAKER_00: Effort to open if someone
doesn't want to try to re-power up the drives
SPEAKER_00: with an engineering power
roll.
SPEAKER_02: Is this while I'm welding?
Yes, you are welding right now. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, well, I'm not it, so I
can do the electronics. I cannot do the
SPEAKER_01: turny-ony.
SPEAKER_00: And hello, Josh.
SPEAKER_02: I would have considered being
a mechanic, but then I would have
SPEAKER_02: literally just been a
copy-paste from my space pirate radio character.
SPEAKER_02: I can be not the engineer this
time.
SPEAKER_00: So Josh has a power of zero.
At least he has it.
SPEAKER_00: Cold does not have any
engineering.
SPEAKER_02: I don't think anyone else has.
I'm inspirational. I have
SPEAKER_02: engineering, but I'm busy.
Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Steinbach also has a zero, so
you guys could work together to do a boon
SPEAKER_00: on it. Yeah, that is probably
the best plan. Josh or Steinbach do a
SPEAKER_00: roll, and the other gives them
the boon.
SPEAKER_02: Steinbach, you want to do it
and I'll give it a good? No, my system is
SPEAKER_02: still rebooting, so the roll
is all yours.
SPEAKER_02: Can someone roll for me right
now, please? I'm sorry. Yeah. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Engineering, Power, Education
with Boone.
SPEAKER_00: You guys do marginal success.
You have booted it. There is
SPEAKER_00: only, though, three hours of
power. It is empty in the gas.
SPEAKER_00: This is enough, though, for
you guys to open it up. Open up any doors
SPEAKER_00: you want to open. Someone
could start trying to do computer rolls to
SPEAKER_00: boot the main computer.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, if I'm not going to get
electrocuted, I can totally try to do
SPEAKER_01: that. If I can get someone to
hype me up, though, that probably would be
SPEAKER_01: great.
SPEAKER_02: Okay.
SPEAKER_03: You can do it. I'll help. I
don't know. If we've lost our other
SPEAKER_03: leadership person, I also have
a leadership of one.
SPEAKER_00: The other leadership person is
currently welding. So, yes.
SPEAKER_03: In that case, Kiernan,
especially in this space and environment,
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan will start to He talks
a lot about
SPEAKER_03: phantom
SPEAKER_03: Okay. That's much better than
I thought it was going to be. Okay.
SPEAKER_01: That was deep, dude. It's just
electronics, right? It's not computers,
SPEAKER_01: or is it computers, or is it
comms?
SPEAKER_00: It would be, it's gonna start
with computers.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: Perfect roll.
SPEAKER_03: Your fingertip on the glove,
not on the finger, not on the glove on the
SPEAKER_03: numpad. You can't feel the
numpad. You're feeling the glove. A lot of
SPEAKER_03: that.
SPEAKER_00: The computer boots up. Now you
guys can
SPEAKER_00: start doing other roles
automatically at a boom because the computer is
SPEAKER_00: trying to assist. Okay. A half
an hour has occurred.
SPEAKER_00: The Profounder has returned,
and all of you guys are still fine on air,
SPEAKER_00: no one is in danger, but the
Profounder says that,
SPEAKER_00: Sonar says that there is a
small ship that is not responding to
SPEAKER_00: hails coming this way. Oh, no.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, snap.
SPEAKER_00: Do you guys want to stay on
the wreck? They may not notice you.
SPEAKER_00: Or do you all want to get on
the proof under and leave?
SPEAKER_03: I mean... Team, this kind of
sounds like what we were contracted to do
SPEAKER_03: now. Are we tracking these
guys down?
SPEAKER_00: He's saying he's gonna
basically pull them away from you if you guys
SPEAKER_00: need to keep working.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, I'm just concerned about
the oxygen levels. He'll leave you
SPEAKER_00: guys with oxygen.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, that makes me feel
better. I hate swimming in video games because
SPEAKER_01: you always drown, and this is
the ultimate risk of drowning in video
SPEAKER_01: games.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_01: A Morrowind broke me hard.
SPEAKER_00: He leaves enough to reset
everyone that half an hour, so they're
SPEAKER_00: basically back at the four
hours of original start time.
SPEAKER_00: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: Yes. I doubt he has spare fuel
that is compatible with this unit,
SPEAKER_02: or with this ship's energy
system.
SPEAKER_00: He does not, because this
energy ship, you need to have refined
SPEAKER_00: hydrogen. Yeah. And so this
ship doesn't have a self-refiner, so you
SPEAKER_00: just need to either get to the
surface or at least get the engines up
SPEAKER_00: enough to get you guys to the
main base to fuel up there.
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan is going to act as an
exchange. Whenever the oxygen
SPEAKER_03: is brought to them, he's going
to ask permission to come aboard for
SPEAKER_03: whatever maneuver they're
going to do on this ship. He's like, I just
SPEAKER_03: think they will need as many
trained hands-on guns as possible. Are you
SPEAKER_03: guys fine here? Should I help
fly
SPEAKER_02: or should I help shoot?
SPEAKER_00: Well, our goal is to keep
running so they don't stop at you. If we stop
SPEAKER_00: and fight them, they may tell
allies where you are.
SPEAKER_02: Maybe I pilot and someone is
on guns just in case.
SPEAKER_02: We help.
SPEAKER_03: He is. If you guys do not need
our help here, he will kind
SPEAKER_03: of...
SPEAKER_00: I'm saying you don't want to
lose your primary machinist.
SPEAKER_02: No, but Saishi does guns.
SPEAKER_00: Right. Saishi can go, but
Saishi only can basically do guns and recon.
SPEAKER_00: Unless Saishi wants to...
SPEAKER_02: I'm the primary machinist?
SPEAKER_00: No.
SPEAKER_02: I said Alan. Oh, it is Alan.
Alan's
SPEAKER_02: the primary machinist. Wait,
who's the primary machinist? Alan. Really?
SPEAKER_02: What's his number? He's a
three, I think. Are there two?
SPEAKER_02: For Mechanic? You two and he
has two, maybe?
SPEAKER_02: I think we were doing the
welding before you got here. But if we're
SPEAKER_02: trying to get away my... Is
this like a small craft or a spacecraft?
SPEAKER_00: It's a small craft.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: If you guys join there, it's
going to be a protracted fight versus you
SPEAKER_00: guys staying here and
defending the people who
SPEAKER_02: are your allies.
SPEAKER_02: Man, when you say it like
that... We're contracted to leave
SPEAKER_02: them.
SPEAKER_01: They're contracted to leave
us?
SPEAKER_02: No. Wait.
SPEAKER_00: He's not asking you guys to
come. I'm telling you he's gonna pull them
SPEAKER_00: away.
SPEAKER_02: Oh.
SPEAKER_00: He's not demanding you come
with them.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, he's trying to act like
a decoy.
SPEAKER_00: Yes.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, he can.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, okay. So, um... I
SPEAKER_00: would say, let's also say if
we can get to the point where we're going
SPEAKER_00: to need the mechanics again.
Does anyone have life support above zero?
SPEAKER_02: Mine is at zero, so it's not
above zero.
SPEAKER_00: I think everyone has a zero
basically who has engineering at all. Where
SPEAKER_00: is it located under?
Engineering. Okay.
SPEAKER_02: I have an engineer of negative
three.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, so do I.
SPEAKER_02: Okay, so
SPEAKER_00: I would say someone who...
Peter just did the last leadership. If
SPEAKER_00: either Colbert Steinbach can
do a leadership on someone who has
SPEAKER_00: zero on the life thing,
because that's what's going to oxygenate the
SPEAKER_00: ship.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah. I'll do it
SPEAKER_02: then. Okay. So you have a
boom, Josh.
SPEAKER_02: That was a mediocre rule.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. So you're able to pump
out the water, but you're not able to put
SPEAKER_00: in oxygen.
SPEAKER_02: Mm-hmm. So, all of you guys
are
SPEAKER_00: in back suits, but you guys
can actually, like, walk around and touch
SPEAKER_00: things now.
SPEAKER_02: Let's give a quick rundown a
bit of the ship. The ship is
SPEAKER_02: about, I'd say, 60
SPEAKER_02: by
SPEAKER_00: 220 feet. Okay.
SPEAKER_02: What number did I need to roll
to have actually gotten the water, I
SPEAKER_02: mean, the air in? Anything
that would have been a plus one success, so
SPEAKER_02: probably just one more. Wait,
what? It said you have
SPEAKER_02: marginal success zero. Oh, I
see.
SPEAKER_00: On marginal success zero,
you're supposed to have them succeed but not
SPEAKER_00: completely. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: There are a few separated
rooms, but you guys can tell that those rooms
SPEAKER_00: are almost metal placards that
are put up and then sunk
SPEAKER_00: into these clasps on the
floor. They're not permanent enclosures, and
SPEAKER_00: then the entire back half of
the ship could theoretically be removed of
SPEAKER_00: all the individual pieces to
make it one huge, large cargo container.
SPEAKER_00: There are beds for eight.
There was a galley.
SPEAKER_00: As none of you are taking off
your helmets, you don't know what this
SPEAKER_00: place smells like. I can't
admit that it smells very good.
SPEAKER_00: The power is on, but there is
no momentum. I'm sorry, guys. I wasn't
SPEAKER_00: able to get the air in here.
But this is better, I think. It's basically
SPEAKER_00: just filled with carbon
dioxide. Yeah, because it's not hydrogen yet.
SPEAKER_00: It's just filled with carbon
dioxide. Anyone who wants to attempt to do
SPEAKER_00: an M-Drive roll will try to
get the ship to move. Can I do it? Then we
SPEAKER_00: can deal with pilots.
SPEAKER_02: I have a plus three on
M-Drive. What do you have? Oh, wow.
SPEAKER_02: No, it's a one plus two. What
do you have? I have a one on M-Drive.
SPEAKER_00: And what's your education
roll?
SPEAKER_02: Oh, my education is plus two.
Just the same. You go
SPEAKER_02: ahead. I'll give you a boon.
Okay, so roll yours with a boon. Hey! There
SPEAKER_02: you go. The
SPEAKER_02: ship is moving.
SPEAKER_00: It is gradually beginning to
automatically move up.
SPEAKER_00: Now that the computer is
booted and it has momentum, it is attempting to
SPEAKER_00: gradually pull itself away
from the dangerous area with a pilot of zero.
SPEAKER_03: Whoa, whoa, whoa. Stop, stop,
stop. Whoa, look at this. No, no, no. No,
SPEAKER_03: look. Stop. We need stop. He's
taking a big power stance as the whole
SPEAKER_03: thing starts to shift and
move.
SPEAKER_01: Is there an actual problem?
Like, why do we have to stop? Because we
SPEAKER_01: don't have any oxygen.
SPEAKER_03: He doesn't have a working
ship. We cannot fly a working ship up into
SPEAKER_03: space. Stop, ship!
SPEAKER_02: He has no vodka, and he has no
oxygen, not the atmosphere.
SPEAKER_03: We can flood the ship with air
on our way out. Oh,
SPEAKER_03: fuck, so we're just going now?
We're leaving? Goodbye? Sayonara?
SPEAKER_01: No, we don't have Mercer, so
we can't leave. Well then, stop, ship!
SPEAKER_01: Calm down! Oh my god, why are
you always at 11? Just, Kirin, just
SPEAKER_01: take it easy. You're gonna
give yourself a heart attack.
SPEAKER_03: Absolutely not. I will not
listen to this person who is in big tin can
SPEAKER_03: at bottom of ocean, seems
fine, no oxygen, Big fat suit, much heavier
SPEAKER_03: now. Get me the fuck out of
here.
SPEAKER_02: This reminds me of a song,
Should I Stay or Should I Go?
SPEAKER_03: He's stomping around to the
beat and just looks very upset.
SPEAKER_02: I would... Slap him to try to
bring some sense into him and have him
SPEAKER_02: calm down. But he's in a back
suit, so kind of can't do that.
SPEAKER_00: That's the point of gut
punches. I would have slapped and shattered your
SPEAKER_00: helmet, but I'm just going to
punch you in the gut.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, so next thing I guess
Kiernan's going to do is try to see if
SPEAKER_03: there's any kind of working
monitor or screen to see what is going on
SPEAKER_03: and if anything is reacting to
the massive ship flying through the water
SPEAKER_03: now.
SPEAKER_00: Flying is a strong word.
SPEAKER_02: It's moving at about maybe 5
miles an
SPEAKER_02: hour, 5 miles an hour.
SPEAKER_03: And he looks to see a monitor?
Is that how he's seeing that it's moving
SPEAKER_03: so slow?
SPEAKER_00: I would say that, yeah, there
are some readouts that you're seeing that
SPEAKER_00: it's moving that slow. Because
it's not being piloted, and it's only
SPEAKER_00: trying to do gradual
reductions instead of change.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: You're not, like, jumping from
the water.
SPEAKER_03: Within electronics, can
Kiernan do anything to try and get some sensory
SPEAKER_03: stuff working online? I'm not
sure if that is exactly...
SPEAKER_00: I would totally be fine for
either a comms or computer role. Yeah. Or
SPEAKER_00: sensors. What about sensors?
SPEAKER_03: Exactly. That's what I was
saying. I'm like, I'm sure there is a role
SPEAKER_03: for it. It's at a zero. It's
fine. He's just going to see. I have an
SPEAKER_03: electronic sensor's Yeah, then
you will see that Kiernan
SPEAKER_03: stomps over to a monitor,
starts going through some rudimentary codes on
SPEAKER_03: an embed, and he seems to be
intent on getting some kind of way to
SPEAKER_03: look on this big ship out into
the water.
SPEAKER_02: Well, all right. I know you're
messing with the sensor console there.
SPEAKER_02: Are you confident you can
bring that up, or would you like someone to
SPEAKER_02: help you?
SPEAKER_03: I just want it out proper. Do
you know how to do better than me? There's
SPEAKER_03: a ship. There's a ship,
Divulter. All right, all right, all right.
SPEAKER_02: Hold on, hold on. I will go
over and I'll start typing in commands to
SPEAKER_02: see if I can bring up any kind
of sensor feed.
SPEAKER_03: Let's see if we can see what
the Orca is doing.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. If you're ready for the
sensor roll, Patrick?
SPEAKER_00: I am writing. That is a 10.
You are able to get a majority of the
SPEAKER_00: monitors booted up. Some of
the screens are pressure cracked. Others
SPEAKER_00: have, like, OLED kind of bleed
through them.
SPEAKER_00: And, like, the color is
slightly off. But you're able to, enough of them
SPEAKER_00: you're able to look at to kind
of see what's going on. It is moving
SPEAKER_00: up. It has equalized itself.
You are surrounded in a lot of bubbles
SPEAKER_00: and dust as it is lifting off
of the silt it has been under for 40
SPEAKER_00: years.
SPEAKER_03: Okay, nice, nice. What do long
scanners say? Can we find Orca? Can
SPEAKER_03: we find other small ships?
What are they doing? Are they interacting?
SPEAKER_03: What is going on outside?
SPEAKER_02: I will relay the information
that I get from the sensors to the team.
SPEAKER_00: And I'm putting a picture of
the schematic of the boat.
SPEAKER_02: Score. Is someone going to...
I'm guessing I'm staying at the M Drive
SPEAKER_02: station, correct?
SPEAKER_00: If you want to make sure that
it doesn't fluctuate and things don't jump
SPEAKER_00: high and low, yeah.
SPEAKER_02: Is someone in the pilot's
seat? No one's in the pilot's seat.
SPEAKER_02: Don't we have another pilot
who's really good
SPEAKER_01: in the team?
SPEAKER_00: I think someone else does have
Smallcraft, maybe Laura.
SPEAKER_02: I have Spacecraft, but not
Smallcraft.
SPEAKER_01: I also have Spacecraft, but I
have Smallcraft at zero.
SPEAKER_00: You could attempt to roll.
Anytime you have something at a
SPEAKER_02: number one on the top, you're
going to have anything in the subs, you'll
SPEAKER_02: have a zero automatically.
SPEAKER_01: Right, but I have a pilot
again at zero as well.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I don't want to do too
much, you know? Same here. I have a...
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, same here.
SPEAKER_00: I've got... You can have two
pilots with zero sit and booze each other
SPEAKER_02: on each other. I'm at one and
zero is what I'm at.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, you actually have one. I
don't think that changes the
SPEAKER_02: role, to be honest. What?
Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Josh, you have a small craft
at one?
SPEAKER_02: No, I have pilot at one and
small craft at zero versus zero and zero.
SPEAKER_00: No one should have a crime
skill at one.
SPEAKER_02: My pilot is at zero. My pilot
is at zero.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, I'm looking at Josh's
sheet, and it does say pilot zero, capital
SPEAKER_00: ship zero, small craft zero,
and spacecraft one.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I think that was in the
old system, maybe.
SPEAKER_03: Maybe it's switched, or now it
automatically drops the prime skills down
SPEAKER_03: to zero.
SPEAKER_02: If someone wants, I can boon
them from the M drive, like giving
SPEAKER_02: directions.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah. So, Josh, how about you
roll and Laura boons
SPEAKER_00: you? Okay. Or the other way
around.
SPEAKER_01: I can boon him. Okay, I was
going
SPEAKER_02: to ask you to roll. Okay, I'll
roll.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, yeah. You're able to
increase the speed now. You're able to
SPEAKER_00: equalize the momentum. That
Alan doesn't have to sit at that sensor
SPEAKER_00: anymore. And you're able to
start telling it where it's going. Because
SPEAKER_00: there is a sensor active right
now, you could choose to go to the
SPEAKER_00: undersea base, but you could
choose to go to the surface, get some air,
SPEAKER_00: and then come back in.
SPEAKER_02: I'm sorry, I'm getting echoed
through. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: I will say now that you've
also been on the ship for a while, one of the
SPEAKER_00: things you realize why the
pilot's captain area exploded out
SPEAKER_00: is they depressurized all the
rest of the ship.
SPEAKER_00: So if only one little spot had
pressure, it all magnified there higher
SPEAKER_00: and higher and higher and
higher until it eventually popped.
SPEAKER_02: And if they depressurized the
rest of it, it would have equalized it a
SPEAKER_02: little bit and they would have
taken less hull damage that way.
Right.
SPEAKER_00: But you still do have 40 years
of crustaceans and other shit, like
SPEAKER_00: living in these jet engines
and all the seals and the stuff.
SPEAKER_02: Can we keep this ship? Or no?
Well, if
SPEAKER_02: it's been down here 40 years,
I would think that there would be some
SPEAKER_02: kind of salvage rights kind of
deal... But it's going to take a lot of
SPEAKER_02: money to fix this up the
proper. But we can call it Sea
SPEAKER_02: Eater.
SPEAKER_01: That's quite the dramatic
name.
SPEAKER_00: By the way, Annette, since you
have been able to walk around pretty
SPEAKER_00: consistently, and you did see
the nature of the piece peeled off,
SPEAKER_00: Is there anything you would
like to be looking at? Because you could
SPEAKER_00: look more for why are things
this way while everyone's been running to
SPEAKER_00: get it up and running.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I mean, if the
investigation was my job, then that's what I'm
SPEAKER_02: going to take that part. What
I'm now mostly
SPEAKER_02: looking for is what sets this
apart from other craft of its type.
SPEAKER_02: If there's been any
modifications to the hull
SPEAKER_02: or reinforcements or
SPEAKER_02: I guess anything to make this
ship
SPEAKER_02: more than what it seems on the
surface. We've already got the idea that
SPEAKER_02: they made the ship,
SPEAKER_02: the wrap around the ship
allowed it to be whatever they needed it to be,
SPEAKER_02: so I'm wondering if there are
any other adaptations they've done to the
SPEAKER_02: ship. I'm not a mechanic, so
I'm mostly just documenting. I'm mostly
SPEAKER_02: just Wandering and looking at,
you know, are the engines what we
SPEAKER_02: expect them to be? Is the, you
know, since I went inside, is the, you
SPEAKER_02: know, is the cabin reinforced
at all? Is there a roll cage installed in
SPEAKER_02: the ship? You know, like
anything that would deviate from...
SPEAKER_00: So, you do see a line of
lockers as water is pouring out of them, and
SPEAKER_00: you start looking through the
lockers, and inside one of them, Is a
SPEAKER_00: dead person in a VAC suit. And
he is holding a shiny metallic
SPEAKER_00: box that's about the size of a
modern shoebox. So it's
SPEAKER_00: four by twelve by...
SPEAKER_02: So this was the Klausner that
got stuffed in the locker. Yeah,
SPEAKER_02: does the lockbox seem latched
shut? Is it openable?
SPEAKER_00: Also, by the way, his Vaxu
says Captain on it. I found the
SPEAKER_02: Captain. Captain goes down
with his ship.
SPEAKER_00: So, as you pull the box out of
his hands, and you do notice that you can
SPEAKER_00: basically kind of screw to
open it, inside are these...
SPEAKER_00: About the size of Pringles
cans. These six Pringles
SPEAKER_00: cans that are filled with
different kinds of clear
SPEAKER_00: electronics and wiring and
tubing
SPEAKER_00: all together.
SPEAKER_02: Does it look complex like
electronics or does it look simple like a
SPEAKER_02: bomb?
SPEAKER_00: It looks much more like
electronics. Okay. I would say electronics could
SPEAKER_00: answer questions about it at a
bane, and a com roll could answer
SPEAKER_00: questions about it normally.
SPEAKER_02: I've got electronics, so I'd
like to just at least do a cursory
SPEAKER_02: examination of it. Absolutely.
Roll away with a bane.
SPEAKER_02: How do I pick a bane again?
SPEAKER_00: When you click on the roll,
there's a section at the bottom that says
SPEAKER_00: normal. Normal, Bane, okay.
SPEAKER_02: And then do I get to add a
stat to it, like int? Yeah, absolutely.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, so you didn't succeed,
but you definitely
SPEAKER_00: realize they're delicate, and
so you pull one up and you look at it and
SPEAKER_00: you put it back in the box.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, if anything, I refuse to
manipulate them enough to even get enough
SPEAKER_02: information to determine what
they are.
SPEAKER_00: They are made, interestingly,
out of different metals. And I don't mean
SPEAKER_00: different metals like one's
iron and one's gold. It's almost like
SPEAKER_00: adonized steel versus rose
gold. It's a manipulation of the
SPEAKER_00: metal to almost mark them.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. I want to see. I send a
SPEAKER_02: video feed to you guys, but I
will also pack up this box, lock it shut
SPEAKER_02: again, or just tear it shut,
and take it with me.
SPEAKER_00: By the way, the original name
of the ship
SPEAKER_00: is called Oyanda, O-D-U-Y-A.
SPEAKER_02: Putable name.
SPEAKER_00: It means openness.
SPEAKER_02: Well, I'm open to taking this
box with me. I'm open to taking the
SPEAKER_02: ship.
SPEAKER_00: It looks, by the way, that
there were four crew on it that are dead.
SPEAKER_00: While they are all corpses,
you can tell that one of them was a gorilla.
SPEAKER_02: Okay.
SPEAKER_02: Not the gorilla. Not the
gorilla.
SPEAKER_00: I will say, also, anyone who
has a computer role could attempt to open
SPEAKER_00: up the pilot logs.
SPEAKER_02: Can I try that, or am I busy?
If you're flying, you're busy.
SPEAKER_01: I will try that. It's not
comms, though.
SPEAKER_02: I'm just going to confirm.
Since there was a sensor role,
SPEAKER_02: does that mean I get to be off
of M-Drive? Because then I wouldn't be
SPEAKER_02: doing anything.
SPEAKER_00: Oh, yeah, because they did,
well, they actually did the pilot to pull
SPEAKER_00: you off of M Drive.
SPEAKER_02: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, so you could roll it,
but Laura hasn't rolled in a while, so I'm
SPEAKER_00: happy to roll it. Yeah, yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
SPEAKER_02: All right.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. So, that's the log.
They're
SPEAKER_02: smugglers.
SPEAKER_00: And one of the key things that
kind of came up was that
SPEAKER_00: they were selling stuff to
their Jordanian syndicate. Okay. With the
SPEAKER_00: fish guy. And they were
basically told to fly by and drop stuff in the
SPEAKER_00: ocean where his dolphin
contacts could pick it up.
SPEAKER_01: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: As they were basically going
by one day, Navy
SPEAKER_00: ship actually saw them in the
drop.
SPEAKER_00: When they came by to basically
say, okay, well, we're going to board you
SPEAKER_00: to find out what's going on,
they realized that other stuff they had on
SPEAKER_00: would have basically, the gig
would have been up.
SPEAKER_02: Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER_00: So they decided to jump into
the water because the boat patrol
SPEAKER_00: couldn't go under the water.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, okay. Did they jump into
the water?
SPEAKER_00: No, like just push themselves
into the water.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah, okay, you meant the ship
into the water when you said jump, not
SPEAKER_01: them as people jumping into
the water.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. Just wanted to confirm.
Absolutely. While they were under there
SPEAKER_00: and they thought, hey, yeah,
it's great that this... Surface boat can't
SPEAKER_00: hit us. They didn't realize
the surface boat had death charges to attack
SPEAKER_00: the dolphins. And they
basically hit it with
SPEAKER_00: a death charge. The pressure
equalization popped the main
SPEAKER_00: aspect of the pilot container
and stunned the crew with the
SPEAKER_00: massive pressure change,
crushing some of their organs. And by the time
SPEAKER_00: Any of them were coherent
enough, they were too physically damaged to
SPEAKER_00: prep the ship and get the ship
out. The computer was online to
SPEAKER_00: see the Navy investigation of
it, and they
SPEAKER_00: basically didn't investigate
it fully because there was a
SPEAKER_00: reactor leak that was spilling
radiation across the area.
SPEAKER_01: Whoa! Okay, well, I
communicate that almost immediately because that
SPEAKER_01: might still be something
that's happening then?
SPEAKER_00: That reactor leak has
currently been sealed by the incredible M-Drival.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so we're not in any
danger of brain cancer immediately.
SPEAKER_00: Right. But because it was just
leaking, it's why the investigators
SPEAKER_00: ignored it until the leak was
sealed by crustaceans. Okay. And then You
SPEAKER_00: guys came in and then you
patched all the work. Okay, we're awesome.
SPEAKER_00: Good job, us. As you guys do
of the videos of the tubes
SPEAKER_00: that Annette has found, is
there anyone who wants to take time to
SPEAKER_00: investigate those? The key
role for it is comms.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, goodness. Now, I've been
running... I've been running sensors...
SPEAKER_02: Is that still an active
checking of that, or can I go over and do
SPEAKER_02: another role as well?
SPEAKER_00: I haven't done anything in a
while.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah, I'm happy you also.
Yeah, I'll calm it up. Okay.
SPEAKER_02: Would that be an intelligence
or an education in this case? I would
SPEAKER_02: accept either of you up
higher.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, you have only seen this
in schematics when you originally went to
SPEAKER_00: school. This is actually ship
transponders.
SPEAKER_02: This is actually ship
transponders, like a ship
SPEAKER_02: identification method.
SPEAKER_00: So you go to the side of the
ship where you know deep in the computer
SPEAKER_00: the transponder is, and
there's actually a plate that lets you put one
SPEAKER_00: of these on. It sucks it deep
into the computer, replaces it, and pops
SPEAKER_00: up the other one. So we can
swap our transponder out.
SPEAKER_02: For just these transponders,
yeah. Well, that's handy.
SPEAKER_00: So you imagine if there's one
probably in it, you have five total
SPEAKER_00: changes.
SPEAKER_03: Karen's going to check if
there's any working guns on here. Unless
SPEAKER_03: there's more to learn,
transponders-wise.
SPEAKER_00: There is no guns. This is a
surface-to-ship transport.
SPEAKER_02: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: You guys can go to other
planets on here as a slowboat, but there's no
SPEAKER_00: jump drive.
SPEAKER_02: No jump drive. Okay. I was
going to ask if I could look for one. Can I
SPEAKER_02: make... So after looking at,
can I,
SPEAKER_02: do you guys relay what you
find with, like, some of the logs? I relay
SPEAKER_02: what I find about the
transponders. Okay. I'm wondering if I could do
SPEAKER_02: another mechanic roll on this
ship to, like, like something that really
SPEAKER_02: needs to get going, you know?
SPEAKER_00: Well, the biggest issue you
would have right now is, I don't know how
SPEAKER_00: much I would trust your guys'
patch job to survive exit or reentry into
SPEAKER_00: space. While it's enough to
hold pressurization
SPEAKER_00: for the last half hour, you're
at like, I think it's 700 degrees
SPEAKER_00: plus while you're going up and
down through the atmosphere.
SPEAKER_02: Could we spend time over the
next few weeks making it stronger and
SPEAKER_02: better?
SPEAKER_00: Absolutely. Like an extended
mechanical sort of thing? Yeah. But you
SPEAKER_00: also have to buy plates.
SPEAKER_02: Yeah. And to do that, we've
got to dock it somewhere where we can get
SPEAKER_02: access to it, which means
we're theoretically docking this at the
SPEAKER_02: TransStar port.
SPEAKER_00: I don't even think that's the
problem. I think the problem is, is where
SPEAKER_00: are we getting this money
from? I will say you guys are now at the
SPEAKER_00: surface, so you guys can open
up the hatches to basically
SPEAKER_00: fill it up with oxygen, and
you guys can take off your back suits.
SPEAKER_02: That would be nice. I wonder
if in any of the logs there might have been
SPEAKER_02: a place where they put their,
I don't want to say treasure, but their
SPEAKER_02: accounts.
SPEAKER_00: You could attempt to start
cracking open containers.
SPEAKER_02: Sure. Are there cargo
containers in that cargo area?
SPEAKER_00: Yep. Sweet. Not a ton, but
there's some.
SPEAKER_03: Let's do it. I mean, Kiernan
will be around for that. I think he'll
SPEAKER_03: probably gather around the
opening of stuffs.
SPEAKER_02: Mm-hmm. I will say real quick,
Patrick, I am going to keep my vac suit
SPEAKER_02: on for at least the first 15
minutes or so and really let the shit begin
SPEAKER_02: to air out a little bit before
I crack a helmet.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, I don't think Kiernan's
taken off his yet, for sure.
SPEAKER_02: He's just clunking his way
through, clunk, clunk, clunk, clunk.
SPEAKER_02: Mm-hmm.
SPEAKER_03: Does anyone have great...
Well, I think I have enough range of motion to
SPEAKER_03: open. Are we opening these? He
kind of cracks his knuckles on these big
SPEAKER_03: fat gloves.
SPEAKER_02: Do we need a roll to
SPEAKER_03: open them?
SPEAKER_02: That's what I was just about
to ask.
SPEAKER_00: I guess here's the question.
If they are sealed, and they've been sealed
SPEAKER_00: for 40 years, you guys can try
to start blowtorching them out.
SPEAKER_00: Or you guys could I would say
a few of them have popped because of the
SPEAKER_00: pressure.
SPEAKER_02: Let's investigate the popped
ones first. That might give us an idea of
SPEAKER_02: what's in here. And then maybe
there's even, if we start digging into
SPEAKER_02: computer codes, maybe there's
access codes to these crates buried
SPEAKER_02: somewhere in the ship's
system. Of course, the locks may be so corroded
SPEAKER_02: that we would have to take a
blowtorch to them anyway. They've been
SPEAKER_02: underwater for 44 decades.
SPEAKER_03: Do we have anyone who's not on
the ship right now? Zoya's not on the
SPEAKER_03: ship, right? Zoya's with the
Orca?
SPEAKER_02: No, I'm here. I just... You
guys are doing all the Rolls App stuff for
SPEAKER_02: us, so you know.
SPEAKER_03: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Do we
have anyone who is not on the ship?
SPEAKER_00: Alan, I guess.
SPEAKER_03: Mercer. That's true. Alan
Mercer.
SPEAKER_01: Other for different Alan.
SPEAKER_02: I need to change his name.
SPEAKER_01: It's technically spelled
Alain, A-L-I-N,
SPEAKER_01: A-L-A-I-N, yeah.
SPEAKER_02: That's how I spelled my name
in French class.
SPEAKER_01: I can't, I could not get that
SPEAKER_01:
A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-L-A-
SPEAKER_00: So the ones that are broken,
as you guys are like peeling them open, you
SPEAKER_00: are seeing some like corroded
metals,
SPEAKER_02: things like that.
SPEAKER_00: So the first box is basically
common raw materials that have been
SPEAKER_00: grinded up. The
SPEAKER_00: second box that is leaking as
you guys open that up,
SPEAKER_00: they are auto rifles that have
basically been destroyed by the water.
SPEAKER_00: The third will actually take
one of you guys grinding it open with
SPEAKER_00: machinery.
SPEAKER_02: Is that a mechanic girl? Yeah,
mechanics. Should I do it?
SPEAKER_03: Sure. Go for it. Do so with
the blessing of a hyper-enthused
SPEAKER_03: looter.
SPEAKER_02: Blessings of his fastest. Is
that
SPEAKER_03: a yes or no? Oh, you've
already rolled, but you rolled well. You
SPEAKER_03: daredevil.
SPEAKER_00: The next box is full of
illegal cybernetic parts.
SPEAKER_01: Oh my god! 40 years old!
SPEAKER_00: What makes him give the
shriek?
SPEAKER_02: But probably it's still worth
something.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, they were
air-pressurized, and they are there.
SPEAKER_03: Oh, happy, happy days! Great
celebration! Yes! Yes, yes, yes, yes,
SPEAKER_00: yes, yes,
SPEAKER_03: yes! He's doing air pumps.
SPEAKER_00: What are these cybernetic
flakes? What are they? Illegal cybernetic
SPEAKER_00: weapons. So, like, hidden guns
that you basically replace your arm with
SPEAKER_00: a hidden gun, or, like, the
full dermal implant piece,
SPEAKER_00: or... Gun links to eyes, so
like you rip out your own eye, but you can
SPEAKER_00: install a thing on your gun,
whatever your gun is looking is what that
SPEAKER_00: eye sees.
SPEAKER_02: We don't have anyone like that
who wants an item like this. I
SPEAKER_02: am. Who's in Karen is waving
his hands right now.
SPEAKER_03: Jumping and waving his hands.
Staring at the cybernetics one.
SPEAKER_02: You guys want to open the last
crate? Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: I wish.
SPEAKER_02: You can do this. I have
absolute faith in your ability to get this out.
SPEAKER_03: Do you want to do it with the
boon? Or maybe I'll help you? Yeah, yeah,
SPEAKER_03: yeah. Do you want me to do it?
Do you want me to do it? Yeah, someone
SPEAKER_03: get him. Someone get him. Get
him with some leadership.
SPEAKER_02: Do it. Yeah, fine. So should I
roll with the boon then, Patrick? Yeah,
SPEAKER_02: Josh roll with it.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. As you open up that one,
you see there is a
SPEAKER_00: full tank that is basically
prepped for hibernation, and as you look
SPEAKER_00: inside the glass of it, there
is a pre that is still alive.
SPEAKER_00: A what? Pre.
SPEAKER_01: T-R-E. Oh. T-R-E.
SPEAKER_01: I don't know. Do I know what
that is?
SPEAKER_02: Is that I am Groot? No.
SPEAKER_00: Yes, there are... It looks a
little like a bonsai or redwood tree.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, you just said T-R-E, and I
was just like, I don't know what that is.
SPEAKER_01: You're saying T-R-E-E. I know
what a tree is.
SPEAKER_02: I saw a gazebo. I wasn't going
to make a presumption.
SPEAKER_00: Some people have to touch
grass.
SPEAKER_02: Uh-huh. What am tree? Tree is.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, but... I will say that
the hibernetic chamber that it's in does
SPEAKER_00: have a security code.
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan raises his eyebrows at
the tree and looks around at the rest of
SPEAKER_03: the people who are near the
box and goes, Okay, before we do anything,
SPEAKER_03: remember, corgis explode. So
just
SPEAKER_03: be aware of that. Corgis can
explode sometimes.
SPEAKER_01: We don't need to really open a
tree, do we?
SPEAKER_03: I don't think we do. I don't
think we need to— Are trees really hard to
SPEAKER_03: come by?
SPEAKER_02: Where's the tree from? Strokes
chain
SPEAKER_02: studies tree. Are there any
SPEAKER_02: info placards or any
documentation in the crate as to where this tree is
SPEAKER_02: from?
SPEAKER_00: I would let someone roll a
science roll if they want to, and if they
SPEAKER_00: have some type of botany, I
would give them a boon.
SPEAKER_03: Gosh. I could roll my science
right now with my cybernetics of Vaughn
SPEAKER_03: and just tear out my eyeball.
Anyone want to see that? Yeah. Okay. I go
SPEAKER_03: for it. I don't know. I don't
actually do that.
SPEAKER_02: I do not have an appropriate
science or science type skill.
SPEAKER_03: Can we roll science for shits
and giggles if we have a science in zero?
SPEAKER_00: Yes.
SPEAKER_03: Okay.
SPEAKER_00: Those giggles will be shat.
SPEAKER_03: Good. Normal, I'm assuming
this is an education roll.
SPEAKER_03: Boom. My science is a negative
three, never mind.
SPEAKER_02: Why did it roll three times?
SPEAKER_00: It rolled three different
rolls. Yeah. But... He
SPEAKER_03: just strokes his chin, squints
his eyes, pops a blood vessel, and
SPEAKER_03: shrugs.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, does anyone have a broker?
Yes. Yeah? I do.
SPEAKER_02: I was just testing something.
If you click the core skill...
SPEAKER_02: It will roll everything that
you have a bonus in under it.
SPEAKER_03: Okay. Oh.
SPEAKER_00: Damien, even though you
failed, you
SPEAKER_00: definitely know there are some
very valuable trees from
SPEAKER_02: different planets.
SPEAKER_02: Some trees are even at the
cost of a ship. Are
SPEAKER_02: they now?
SPEAKER_02: Can I...
SPEAKER_01: I guess I'd like to dig
through their computers and look for an illegal
SPEAKER_01: manifest.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. I will accept a computer
roll with the bane.
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan at this point has lost
a majority of his interest in anything
SPEAKER_03: other than the cybernetics,
which he has begun to try and properly store
SPEAKER_03: in whatever storage units we
might have, so that they're not just in
SPEAKER_03: this box.
SPEAKER_00: Damien, can't you roll another
broker so you guys can also estimate on
SPEAKER_00: how much value you'd get from
the cybernetics? Sure, sure.
SPEAKER_03: Can I roll a broker as well?
SPEAKER_02: Sure, sure. Man, I am just...
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan is practically
appraising him. He puts him, you know, he studies
SPEAKER_03: him, puts him in his hands. I
think at this point the back suit's
SPEAKER_03: probably at least
depressurized and maybe not completely off, but he's
SPEAKER_03: inspecting stuff. Oh my
goodness!
SPEAKER_00: Damon, you think it's
somewhere between 50,000 and 100,000? I,
SPEAKER_02: as a person without broker,
would be skeptical of that number.
SPEAKER_00: I think you should say, as a
person who read what you rolled, I'm
SPEAKER_00: skeptical of that. As a person
who can read. No, I just think of, like,
SPEAKER_00: how expensive it is to get,
SPEAKER_02: like, general cybernetics, and
I'm like, eh, I don't know about that. If
SPEAKER_02: you have a box of them, it
feels like maybe, maybe should be hundreds of
SPEAKER_02: thousands to maybe millions,
but, you know.
SPEAKER_00: You don't understand how much
they're marking
SPEAKER_02: these up.
SPEAKER_00: If we would open up a box,
like if we were in a medical shipyard and we
SPEAKER_00: opened up stuff in America and
it was a box full of stuff, someone's
SPEAKER_00: like, I think like $20,000.
I'm like, do you know how much an MRI
SPEAKER_00: machine is? I don't know about
that. I'm sorry. You know, those GLP-1
SPEAKER_00: drugs doesn't cost them a lot
to make, but they sure sell them for a
SPEAKER_00: lot. But to be fair, I don't
have the broker, so what do I know?
SPEAKER_03: As Zoe and Kiernan are
inspecting the
SPEAKER_03: cybernetics, Zoe, do you have
one in your hand?
SPEAKER_03: Like, how are you interacting
with the cybernetics, Damon?
SPEAKER_02: Probably just looking at them.
Why would I want to be handling this?
SPEAKER_03: Okay, you are nearby. I don't
know if you need to really roll for this.
SPEAKER_03: Kiernan looks visibly not
uncomfortable in like the wary way. He looks
SPEAKER_03: like a little... I don't know,
his vision kind of unfocuses a bit.
SPEAKER_03: He looks a little like almost
perturbed physically that you are
SPEAKER_03: Around the cybernetics,
inspecting them, touching them. There's
SPEAKER_03: something. But he's trying to
shrug it
SPEAKER_03: off.
SPEAKER_00: So, because you guys are
probably thinking it, and you may need to
SPEAKER_00: restrain Peter, if you sell
the cybernetics, it would be enough to get
SPEAKER_00: you Refuel the plates
necessary to rebuild it, the replacement
SPEAKER_00: monitor screens, and someone
to clean out the literal smell of death.
SPEAKER_00: That wouldn't be a bad idea.
SPEAKER_03: I'm crying. I'm crying. But
we'll get more. Leave me an eye. Leave me
SPEAKER_03: one eyeball. Please, sir.
Please, sir, one eyeball.
SPEAKER_01: Did that mess up your genetic
purity? You're replacing your body parts?
SPEAKER_03: Ah, see, that is an astute
thought, Emma. Yes, that
SPEAKER_03: is a very, very smart
conclusion. The thing is, I have
SPEAKER_03: already succeeded in my
calling and necessity to pass on my genetic
SPEAKER_03: code. And as such... I am
always a laser in my head. Ah, what?
SPEAKER_03: Sorry. I didn't hear what you
said. You're fine. So,
SPEAKER_03: yeah, no. I've had kids. I did
service in the military. I did it. The
SPEAKER_03: only thing that I have left...
SPEAKER_01: Your purity is still who you
are as an individual. I mean, do what you
SPEAKER_01: want and become impure as you
feel you need to be. Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Okay. I see Patrick has his
hand raised. That's all on him.
SPEAKER_00: I just want to know, are you
guys just letting it just, like, Bob, on
SPEAKER_00: the water here, are you guys
going to take it to the Navy docks, or are
SPEAKER_00: you guys going to attempt to
deal with the pressure of putting it back
SPEAKER_00: down to the Transtar ocean
base?
SPEAKER_03: Whatever we need to do.
SPEAKER_02: I think once we have air in
here, we should take it back under.
SPEAKER_02: Otherwise, we'll have to deal
with the Navy. Okay, let's do it.
SPEAKER_02: I actually have a question
real quick. Can I roll broker to thank where
SPEAKER_02: we could get the best deal for
selling all this stuff? Sure. Okay.
SPEAKER_02: See if I can seed ones
tonight. No, I have not.
SPEAKER_00: Okay, so. Well, I'll give you
the obvious answer that you're not going
SPEAKER_00: to like. Yeah.
SPEAKER_01: Yeah.
SPEAKER_00: The Rebels.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, I thought you were going
to say the Dolphins.
SPEAKER_00: Well, the terrorists that are
in the caves that you
SPEAKER_00: guys heard about, I bet they
buy this stuff pretty well. I
SPEAKER_00: would say number two is the
Dolphin. If he had won success, I would have
SPEAKER_00: said the Jordan City
Syndicate. But because he had no successes, I've
SPEAKER_00: got to save the terrorists.
SPEAKER_00: If you guys sold this to
Transtar, you're going to be getting about 35%
SPEAKER_00: of the cost.
SPEAKER_03: At that point, you might as
well just put it in my eyeball. What the
SPEAKER_03: heck?
SPEAKER_01: Can I roll broker to know if
there's a better customer out there?
SPEAKER_01: Absolutely.
SPEAKER_02: Can I inspire you? Julie,
that's fine. It doesn't need it.
SPEAKER_02: Nice. Okay, you've got three
successes. What do you want to know? Oh,
SPEAKER_00: I will give you one piece. All
the sanity of Vernetics have been removed
SPEAKER_00: from people.
SPEAKER_02: Oh, yes. Oh, yes.
SPEAKER_01: So, I'm going to just kind of
think this out loud for a hot minute.
SPEAKER_01: Like, I feel like our goal is
to fix this shit up,
SPEAKER_01: ship up to, sorry, Freudian
slip.
SPEAKER_03: Nah, that worked. Both can be
true.
SPEAKER_01: Both, yeah, both things can be
true. Fix this ship up. To essentially
SPEAKER_01: sell it to get a better ship.
I feel like that's the meta goal to an
SPEAKER_01: extent. But if we're still
thinking we can clear our name, we just need
SPEAKER_01: to get it to a Navy ship
that's already in space so that we can drop
SPEAKER_01: Mercer off and get his
information from his house and his computer.
SPEAKER_00: So let me first explain the
meta. No, this is meant to be the
SPEAKER_00: stairwell of you guys will
then explore other planets in the solar
SPEAKER_00: system to solve parts of the
mystery.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so the solutions are not
entirely on this planet.
SPEAKER_00: Right. You're going to hit a
wall of data that's going to make you need
SPEAKER_00: to get information from
another planet. This ship, while it can't jump,
SPEAKER_00: can get you to other planets.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, I wasn't really aware of
that. Okay. So, in that case,
SPEAKER_01: then, yeah, I would try to
think with my soul set contacts, because I
SPEAKER_01: have 101 of them, if any of
them would be willing to
SPEAKER_01: offload any kind of
merchandise like this for a fair price.
SPEAKER_00: I would say absolutely,
because you do have a million and one contacts.
SPEAKER_00: I would say that you have a
contact that will basically give you 50% of
SPEAKER_00: the cost of it. Without there
being any questions because you are wanted
SPEAKER_00: criminals.
SPEAKER_02: Right.
SPEAKER_00: And I will even say because
they'll trade in
SPEAKER_00: service to repair the ship. So
you guys don't need to do extra
SPEAKER_00: rolls to actually do it
yourself.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. Sorry, I'm trying to
read through my contacts to see if there's
SPEAKER_01: one that's appropriate. Anita
Singh could be... The problem is
SPEAKER_01: the descriptions get cut off,
so I have to open each one individually.
SPEAKER_01: Oh, yeah. So Anita Singh is a
sharp-witted entrepreneur whose logistics
SPEAKER_01: consortium quietly controls
warehousing, orbital freight handling, and
SPEAKER_01: labor contracts across several
confederation starports. She definitely
SPEAKER_01: has a transtar day. She
definitely has a transtar day. Okay.
SPEAKER_00: So she's definitely willing
to...
SPEAKER_01: Here's the guy who operates a
loose smuggling network, moving restricted
SPEAKER_01: pharmaceutical drug records
and occasionally people. That's Sergei's
SPEAKER_01: son.
SPEAKER_02: How about this?
SPEAKER_00: You can sell the stuff to them
to get the ship working. And your other
SPEAKER_00: contact, you can get Mercer
off World so you guys get the codes.
SPEAKER_01: Okay, so I'll have Anita
fenced the stuff, and then Sergei, because he
SPEAKER_01: occasionally moves people, we
would use him to get
SPEAKER_01: Mercer off-world.
SPEAKER_00: Where I think we're going to
stop here, because what we're going to
SPEAKER_00: start next game is you guys
can actually activate the pad to see what's
SPEAKER_00: on the computer pad that he
died with. Okay. And we'll
SPEAKER_00: do the weekend you guys have
of your TransStar work schedule. So you
SPEAKER_00: guys can actually go to
Mercer's house and see what's available there.
SPEAKER_00: And you guys then have an
active ship you guys can take to orbit and fly
SPEAKER_00: to other planets that are in
the system. To also bring into a deeper
SPEAKER_00: meta, I think when you get
another bigger ship that has a jump drive,
SPEAKER_00: you're going to put this in
it. Okay.
SPEAKER_02: So this will be a boat. You
have two ships?
SPEAKER_00: So intense!
SPEAKER_02: So we can give two ships?
SPEAKER_00: Yes, we can give two ships
SPEAKER_02: about it.
SPEAKER_00: Two ships about it. This is
the basic ship boat schematic from
SPEAKER_00: Highguard. So these things
are, like, even if you had a far trader, you
SPEAKER_00: could probably put this in a
far trader.
SPEAKER_01: Okay. Yeah, that's the part of
Traveler I don't know anything really
SPEAKER_01: about.
SPEAKER_00: Right. It would take up almost
all your cargo, but you could put it in a
SPEAKER_00: far trader. And a far trader
is like the first
SPEAKER_00: ship that commonly has jump.
SPEAKER_02: I see.
SPEAKER_00: Yeah, like some scout ships
and some mail ships have jump as well, but
SPEAKER_00: the most common ship that
someone can actually pay their mortgage off on
SPEAKER_00: is basically a far trader. And
to give you guys like a
SPEAKER_00: concept of cost, a ship boat
is about a tenth the
SPEAKER_00: cost of a basic ship with a
jump.
SPEAKER_02: A tenth? Anything else about
right, Steinbach? I'm sorry, I started
SPEAKER_02: multitasking on something
else. I missed the question.
SPEAKER_00: Would you say a ship boat is
about a tenth the cost of a jump drive
SPEAKER_00: capable ship? A basic jump
drive ship, yeah.
SPEAKER_00: Basically like a far trader
versus a ship boat. Ten ship boats basically
SPEAKER_00: would cost a far trader.
SPEAKER_02: That's so expensive.
SPEAKER_00: Hey, but a ship boat can be a
down payment for a far trader. Well, I'd
SPEAKER_00: like to also bring the last
point up. So when you jump into a system,
SPEAKER_00: you don't necessarily jump
near the planet. You guys can then go in the
SPEAKER_00: ship boat, change the
transponder, and be a smuggler.
SPEAKER_02: Yep.
SPEAKER_00: Or just sneak past the guards
if you guys need a key piece of
SPEAKER_00: information. Or go pick up a
friend you need
SPEAKER_00: rescued. Having this shipboat
with the transponder changer allows you
SPEAKER_00: guys to do a lot of
interesting stuff on a planetary scale, if not a
SPEAKER_00: system scale. Because normally
the moment you jump in,
SPEAKER_00: And you fly somewhere, you've
been screaming your transponder the whole
SPEAKER_00: time, everyone knows who you
are every time. This lets you get some
SPEAKER_00: momentum of them knowing a
different identity every time.
SPEAKER_00: And even though you guys
didn't experiment it, so three of the
SPEAKER_00: transponders are different
polarities in the Traveler universe. One is
SPEAKER_00: an Imperium transponder. One
is an Aslan transponder.
SPEAKER_00: Whoa. So, there are two
Soleimani transponders of the
SPEAKER_00: five. One is exceptionally
old, before
SPEAKER_00: the wars, and one is kind of
new, so one basically is like how,
SPEAKER_00: what's his name, Din Djarin is
like, oh yeah, I have an old transponder.
SPEAKER_00: That kind of vibe. So, that's
the gist of it. I hope
SPEAKER_00: everyone had fun. It was
great. Thank you so much.
SPEAKER_02: Thank you. Good game, Neil.
SPEAKER_03: Well, yes. This was a great
time.
SPEAKER_00: Great times. Great times.
SPEAKER_02: Okay. Thank you, Patrick.
Bye-bye, all. Bye-bye. Thank you, guys. Nice.